Top of the Stevia. I see. I just need
to superior to sugar in many ways. Yeah.
It's not bad for you at all. Yeah.
Yeah. I don't think it didn't.
The sugar lobby get fucking pretty pissed
about it. Yeah. They should get that.
We should talk about this. Okay.
All right. That's good. Oh,
I say so many amazing things.
That's where you start doing a podcast.
You start going, don't talk outside
of that. No Rogan experience.
Don't have it.
[inaudible]
the headphones that I have on [inaudible].
These are
why we made it to the end of the song.
Uh,
what the fuck people, oh,
is that your phone run?
No,
that's pacnet had Tom Chung.
Marcel always have this thing
going on where you're cuter.
We'll start playing things.
That's his playlist.
My computer never just starts
playing shit out of nowhere.
What is your computer started
playing? Shit. It's on iTunes.
It just goes to the next song. That's
your, that's your sexy time on iTunes.
It goes to the next song, right? Yeah. I
just play it so you just fucked up. Right.
Well that makes sense. Yeah. Ladies and
gentlemen, welcome to the pog drives.
What's off? What's on
bedrooms? What's going on?
People working the fucking late chef,
people driving in the car,
people hating their life and needing
something to distract them from whatever
bullshit you got yourself into right now.
It's going to get better.
Ladies and gentlemen, can I get better,
right Brian? Yes, rob, any better?
But it can only get better if
you have a flashlight. Yes.
And we are sponsored by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net there's a link.
If you click the link,
you enter in the code name,
Rogan, you get 15% off. And I've,
I've humped them all in my
former Chris's fuck all of them.
There's so many combinations.
All of them done and they're great.
Which of which one's your favorite?
Mine's the Avatar, by the way.
I mean the alien aliens. Aliens. All
right. It's pretty good. But the,
for me it's the lotus because it's
confusing. It tricks me actually,
which will load at 6.0 the Lotus Lotus.
We designed,
I say we in the royal we sense,
cause you know I was Chris,
Chris Markus laser device.
Chris is our buddy and Chris used to work
for flashlight and he's also a writer
and just an all around cool cat and
entrepreneur out there in the world making
shit happen. Thank you Joe. So this
lotus then you help design this,
modified that and I wanted
to try and recreate,
cause we do a good job with the exterior
of the vagina. Right. I want to do,
which by the way is
completely unnecessary. Right.
You know I used to have a joke about that.
If you just put a round hole in the
wall we'll fuck. Right, right. Yeah.
It doesn't have to look like a fake
pussy. But the interior is key. Yes.
Sounds absolutely.
And wanting to try and create something
that was confusing and really actually
felt as close as possible.
And I think I did a decent job with the
loudest because it has this little note
in there that's kind of,
you know,
like when you're getting to the back
and you start to feel a little something
that's coming in and giving you a little
pressure and you kind of slide around
it or something like that.
I don't exactly know how it works.
Talking about the back of the vagina,
but there, but there's like a, yeah,
it's called watch.
You gotta be careful with those pitches.
You just have speed bumps on the
bitch gives you go to a doctor,
get some shit cold laser.
It's like where the cauliflower,
where it starts feeling like
color flour. Right, right, right.
That's well I want some video
online ones. The g spot, by the way,
the board of stupid flowers. Is
that what it is? Yeah, really.
But every girl is different.
I mean you can't really say it's a g spot.
The cauliflower part is. Right, but you
know what I'm saying? I'm like every good,
there's certain spots. It's not every,
everybody doesn't have the same spot.
I always thought that's silly.
Like when you watch like push eating
competitions or a instructionals rather on
the Internet. You're seeing those, right?
I've seen a few of them is
in instructional. When you,
when you're eating out a girl
and you're like up at the top,
put that finger or two in and hit
the cauliflower, it just massage it.
While you're looking at instant orgasms,
you pull a Toro point towards the end,
almost pressure. You almost
[inaudible] motion come hither motion.
Every girl's got a different groove.
You know,
like some girls want you to just lock
on that motherfucker and go crazy really
fast. Tom, some of the girls
like gentle, slow, gentle,
slow because they don't trust me.
They're cute.
They're putting no trust in you when
you do that. I don't know if that's it.
I think it is.
I don't know if that's it.
I think girls are levels desensitivity
yeah, the different shit.
Some girls like it to blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And other girls are, they just haven't
gone the other way. Same with nipples.
I mean some girls, yeah,
whack them with a fly.
Swatter girls will tell you to bite their
nipples by other girls. You touch them.
They're like,
whoa.
Like it's an interesting thing with
some girls that it seems that pain has
become some sort of a sexual thing.
You know, it's not every girl,
but there are certain girls that pain for
whatever reason, turns him on, you know,
like they like to be manhandled
and choked and slapped and,
and spanked and shit. And I like
to be fucked hardware. It hurts.
Like you look at them, you're like, you
know, it hurts face, but she's loving it.
You know what the fuck is.
It has an evolutionary biological
advantage because I think, you know,
sex back in the day was rough, brutish,
short, violent, you know, and you know,
it just may way. That's how
I still rock. It made sense.
The girl that fucked the new school,
you know?
And actually when a girl obviously is
more excited, she's more open to actually,
she has a greater chance of conceiving.
I've read about that in a book called
sperm wars, which is a great book. Yeah.
Let's see here. Moore's, I've heard. Okay.
I looked into all of this
because there was a, um, uh,
an article that I read a couple
articles I read about killer sperm,
that there are certain sperm that go
out and attack other sperm. So, um, I,
I read this on more than one source
online and from that book, sperm wars by,
what's his name? Baker. Yeah.
I believe his name was Dr.
Baker. Um, so then I read,
um,
some,
some different responses to that and
apparently there's no evidence to support
it whatsoever. The only
evidence to support, um, that,
that there's like some sort of a,
a blocking system going on.
There's evidence to support that,
that there's always the why sperm is gooey
and sticky because one of the reasons
why I got up at work, it's trying to
clog up the works for other dudes. Yeah.
And there's also very strong
evidence that no matter the,
there's a direct correlation
between not just strong evidence,
but it's been proven between the
promiscuous nature of the females of the
population and the size of the
testicles and the males. Yeah.
That the males just produce more sperm.
But that's just so they could shoot
more loads and have more chances.
It's not that there's actually sperm that
are going out there and killing other
spring. So that's sperm wars book
is a little warmth. Iffy, Huh? Yeah.
It's a little wonky.
But the uh,
the idea behind the woman
orgasming OpenAir up and making,
they're more likely to conceive
then you would think that,
well then the rape thing probably wouldn't
be the best thing. The best move. No,
but you know, if so, so how it
passes through sexual selection is,
is the girl who actually
threw some genetic mutation
finds that attractive that
that kind of rough brute kind of rape
scenario attractive is going to produce
more stem, you know, vaginal fluid,
which is going to help conduct the sperm
a little better and be more open to it.
So she's going to be
more likely to conceive,
meaning there'll be eventually over time
an advantage for the females who like
that kind of dominant scenario in
cultures that have dominant sex. Right.
And they're also gonna be cohabitating
with dominant males in that way.
You're going to have someone who's going
to protect you and get some shit done.
Yeah,
send us some week,
three quarter lymphatic dude's just barely
sticks in these squeezes out of slug
needs.
The split it with a popsicle stick.
Make your shitty genetic baby to go out
and get raped by a tyrannosaurus rex or
some shit. Right. All right, so you
were talking about the flashlight,
I that you were designing that.
Tell us how many designs there are.
The one you were designing the Lotus.
Yeah. So how many are there? Ah,
there's gotta be 1617 different
internals in the variations are different
tightness. Like what is it a different
texture whenever you could think of,
I mean,
I mean it was really a matter of long
experience with feeling these things out
and then you just come up with shit,
you know,
like all this would be interesting and
you try it. You know, they build a rod,
try it out and some of them are smash
hits and some of them are like, man,
you know, does he ever started developing
some sort of a cleaning sponge thing?
Like a very small penis like sponge
that's attached to like sick of wire that
comes swiffer. Yeah. Comes with
exactly something to get in there and
yeah. Well I mean so sticky inside anyway.
It's like,
so the material is tough to come up
with something that would actually slide
that was poorest itself
that could actually clean.
Otherwise there'd be just like a,
you know,
a dildo hardness going ever been recorded.
Instance of a dude using a fleshlight,
having a venereal disease,
leaving his load and a flush and then
another sick fuck using the flashlight and
getting that dude's disease. No, no,
no, no recorded. And that's possible.
How long will herpes last on the
plastic surface of the flashlight? Um,
that's a good question.
I don't know.
But we recommend Washington
them out every now and again.
Water would help. Well he's sharing it
with Joe that you might be worried about.
Just saying [inaudible] you have one,
it's all yours.
You don't need to share with us a kind
looking homeless guy down this track.
I don't want them to mind right
now. Bobby Lee, you me to share.
Bobby Lee was on our show last last
week and he's a huge supporter of the
vibrating one that has the
little rechargeable beads
right now. He said that,
that he, they only last five minutes.
Does he have a defect one or no,
the last 60 minutes. 60
minutes. So he has a defect.
Maybe he's just cause he's like
halfway through and stop rushes. Well,
you can handle, you just squeezes
it so hard against the side though.
Is that how it works? The harder you
squeeze it, the more Rev. Now I dunno.
I mean these things are, you know,
they have a little little engine,
little off centered little motor
in it and it lasts about, you know,
last about 60 minutes and B,
if you moved the boat,
move closer to the mic so that you all
have the same different volumes. Um,
and it fits right into the slot.
Yeah. So like every one of them,
that little three slots in the head and
usually you can only fit one or two in
there, uh, with yourself.
But we have three slots just in case and
just whoever's vibrates your Dick. Yeah,
I, you know, some people like it. I think
it's more distracting. I don't really,
I'm not a big fan of the vibration. Yeah.
I don't be Lego's good. Where's the,
where is the fantasy cause
what am I fucking that girl
and what am I fine Gorana
washing machine. Fucking a robot, right.
On a washing machine in a hurricane or
during an earthquake. Yeah. There's some,
there's some really good products but
another company called screaming out and
it's like are vibrating cock ring and
they've kind of taken that market,
which is awesome for the chicks.
But it's,
I find it kind of a little bit annoying
for me to have it on because the
vibration is just distracting.
Like you feel less like imagine your
hand like on a massager and then try to
like feel something cool
propeller feel anything. Right.
And then also what if like the CIC only
wants it with that vibrating contract.
You're like my cock and
balls and not enough. Right.
It has to turn yourself into a really
did annoy you man. Robo Cock. Yeah,
because I dated a dude,
I dated the chick who dated,
dated a chick who dated a dude and they
had a bad relationship and one of the
bad problems in their relationship with,
she got addicted to vibrators. Yep.
Very much addicted and really get it
girl that was addicted to it. Yeah. Did,
it was first of all,
what's up with bitches telling you
like problems they had with other dudes
sexually like fucking stop.
All right.
Because we know you're going to do that
to us too. You fucking creep, right.
Tattletale creep. You know that
a lot of girls like, you know,
and then he couldn't get it
up and then God, I was like,
is sent me and they're like, half of this
is you just trying to get me excited,
but like, look, I can get it up. Fuck
him. Don't worry about him. You know,
engaging in that sort of
a weird guy, masculine ego
thing where like, or you know,
like wow, this poor girl,
she needs some Dick.
She's letting me know she needs object.
Like it's a little banter
and game you play. But, um,
this girl apparently could not come
without like for like a long time.
Like she had a wean herself off of it.
Right.
You have not used anything for like a
year. She, she used to use shower heads,
so used to use the uh,
the faucet account.
Apparently when you're in the tub you
can crank that mother fucker fuck her up.
And she was built shoes,
the perfect height to slider pussy
right underneath the thing and just get
blasted on the snatch by the
fucking full stream of water.
And that's how she would orgasm.
Shoot our guys, I'm doing that.
And she would organize them with
vibrators and so like, she would like,
like fuck her dude and just be like,
you done? You done. Okay, good. Eh,
which has gotta be annoying
as fuck the dude. You know,
like if you're a chick wants you to put
that cock ring on all the time and like,
come on, really? Right. What are we doing
here? All right, fuck. Are we doing here?
I said hot brands, it's all
about this. I love baby.
He started becoming the chick, you know,
she just told me, can you just hold me?
Why do I have to put it in your ass?
Yeah. It is funny though, the psychology
that the changes, if you're not,
if you don't really feel like you've
done the best job you could with a check
box here, you'll catch yourself
being not yourself. Fuck yeah.
You seem like a weak bitch,
like given extra long massages.
Like why are you,
what am I doing here?
Oh Dude. Yeah, guys have
sexual problems, man.
You could always see it
in the relationship. The
relationship is always bad.
They can't fuck right. Yep. Know. I know
dudes that you get addicted to porn,
you know? And uh, I've talked
to a couple of guys, you know,
Bobby Lee was talking to us about it,
that Bobby Lee has a hard time getting
it up because he's just addicted to porn
cause he watches porn so much.
And then I'm like, you know,
you would like a regular girl and you're
like, what's all this? What is this?
What am I doing here? What am I doing
here? What is your heels, right. You know,
this is all your real hair.
What the fuck?
You can't even wear your fake eyelashes.
You know, how can we, tits aren't hard.
Yeah. The fuck is going on. And he likes
the HD one. He's like pays for it. Yeah.
You buys the DVD,
he gets
tardy. He gets up in there.
Yeah. Yeah. I don't know TV.
It's a weird thing when people get really
like connected to some one particular
thing that turns you on, you know?
And when some guys, man, it gets it,
it stops being regular.
People starts being the porn.
Yeah. Yeah. I guess that's,
that's the guy's trap is the
porn and the girls is the,
is the vibrator sort of,
I mean,
girls get to porn to write,
don't girls get addicted to porn?
Yeah. I mean, I know a couple of girls.
Esther's addicted to porn, right though.
Like really ask like a guy
addicted, but she doesn't like, uh,
like 12 videos on her
phone of porn videos.
I don't even have porn videos on my phone.
I just fucking go to like, you know,
some streaming porn site.
That might be a factor.
The fact that she can't find very many
good ones, so she's got to save him.
You know what I'm saying? Like porn. It's
good for girls. It's hard to come by.
She bought, she bought Jenna Jamison
sweater off Ebay addicted to porn.
Whoa.
How many loads on that
sweater she's Christ have.
You can make a whole army of humans.
Would that sweater just throw
that sweater head throw.
That's one or two a few scientists
and go yo, there's some shit in there.
Do what you gotta do. Get some
biological material. Clone it.
You'd have a Goddamn army.
Have you seen curses photo from Halloween
from two Coleen's ago where they all
him and all his friends all dressed up
as the characters from street fighter.
By the way,
I'm not that Jen and Jenna says
having sex with anyone other
than Tito Ortiz was just jokes.
Nobody get a fucking hurt pussy over
this. No sand, your vagina pleases.
These are just jokes. I
love Jenna Jameson. I love
Tito. These are just jokes.
You might be able to find loads
on my sweater too. How about that?
Maybe more than hers. It's happened.
Maybe more loads. Maybe Tito's.
Maybe I'm experimenting
with a gauntlet of loads,
but yeah, on his website.
Warrior poet, die or walk.
Chris's website. Warrior. Yeah.
Chris is worry about warrior poet.us,
right? Yep. I it, he's got a great photo.
You got to check out. It's hilarious. I
mean they all look exactly like the staff.
We got the full street fighter
four 16 person cast. Yeah.
He had like you had the shave
talking about just random people in
the streets. No, all our buddies. Oh,
you guys are dorks. You guys like those
Avatar people that pretend to be blue.
Kill out. Rick made Avatar. We
recreated the father's home tree.
Yeah, but if he's still on
that, I saw that on Halloween.
You, you'd be like, wow,
that's fucking right.
Mason. There was a really funny,
a online video. Where was that?
It was a spoof of these avatar people
that recreate avatar and it was like,
you know, it was just a parenting.
It was, but it was really funny.
But the funny thing is
that people really do that,
but at least if you're doing avatar,
you're doing something fantastical and
w and w fantasy filled in. Wonderful.
What about these assholes that pretend
they're in the civil war? Right. You know,
we're going to recruit a boodle where
you were going to come over the hill,
go through food, you know you're going
to fall. Yeah. What do you do? It's on,
did you guys hear about just be one
thing if they had paintball guns,
your website or a crush your
website stat into stride scenarios.
Well, we just crushed your website back
quickly to welcome to the power of the
podcast. It, it got my
webmaster, is it wordpress?
Does their mother fucking saga continues?
Yeah.
We've crushed many a website on the show.
I actually enjoy doing it now.
There's something I like to mention a
website and watching them all the fucker
bolster the bolster,
the defenses.
It's more of a flow of wordpress
got problems with ours, man.
We've had problems
whenever the podcast run.
So I'm just got to separate everything
on the two servers cause I've a message
board and a regular blog and
when the podcast hits you
can access it through the,
the the regular blog.
And when you access it through the blog,
it's like everything else just slows
down to a fucking creep because there's
thousands of people hitting.
And really honestly not that many.
I mean it's only like a
couple of thousand at a time.
It's amazing like how little it
takes to crush a website, you know,
a couple thousand hits at
once and it just crushed.
What the fuck are we prepared for it.
It's kind of weak ass shit is this,
you know,
it's not like a television where everyone
could tune into distinction at the
same time.
It's a flawed system.
But if you have, if you have a server
set up right and prepared for that,
you'll be fine using like cloud servers.
But the problem is is you know,
you get your private
server and that's just,
if you think about a private server is
one computer. So imagine 2000 people.
We have appeared to have a
dedicated server for that
and a couple of other sites,
but we probably should go to the cloud,
go to the cloud.
So I'm to go to the cloud bitches.
Did you hear about that NBC employee
that got fired because leaked a video of
Bryant Gumbel and whatever that chick's
name from the today show from 1994 where
they were talking about the Internet
and they both did not know what the
Internet was. 94 I know. Who the
fuck. Who the fuck cares, right?
The guy got fired from NBC cause he put
it on Youtube and now NBC is trying to
take down the clip from youtube. I mean
it, why? Cause they look like fools. Yeah,
it's 94 okay,
so but play it,
we have to find out how someone lost
their job offers. Here is these,
you know what it is man?
It's the infrastructure.
These old fucks that are still
in charge of these corporations.
They just have not caught
the fuck up. Okay, here we go.
[inaudible] what they say
and then the ring around it.
So that's where I said, okay. You said
you thought it was about, yeah. Oh,
they didn't know what at means.
Tom Content.
All right, mark, but then where I said I
love it. Can you turn it louder? Abroad.
That's allows again.
What are you around in the lecture?
We say I at NBC. Ge Calm. I mean,
well, what Alison should
know. What is the loud anyway?
Internet is a massive computer at work.
The one that's becoming really big now.
What do you mean?
That's a big way I was wanting to know
with what are you white taught? Like male.
A lot of people use it.
Communicate if,
I guess they can communicate with
NBC writers and producers. Elephant,
can you explain what Internet is? No, she
can't say anything. 10 seconds or less.
Oh,
Alison will be in the studio shortly.
What did what the name Peter Never
made up? Made up of? Started from,
Oh, I thought you were
gonna tell us what this was.
If you're looking at the numbers,
it's
still a university. Right. And
others could access it, right?
It's getting bigger and bigger role.
Just really handy during the quake.
A lot of people,
that's how they were communicating
out to tell family and loved ones.
They were okay because all
the phone lines were down.
I was telling Katie and over again,
you don't need that.
You don't need a phone line to
operate it out. No, probably not.
So Katie was talking to a lot of people
out there like who are afraid to go to
sleep. Really? Yeah. They're scared
to go stick. A lot of people,
particularly those who live alone are,
are afraid to be there.
They're getting into bed.
Did Jamie share,
how did you segue from the Internet
to being scared to go to sleep alone?
They'll start off with a tremor will
come through [inaudible] talk more about
dinner and again go back to sleep and
there were a lot of people now who are
suffering from sleep deprivation.
Okay,
let's just kill it right there. That's
fascinating. I'm saving that right now.
I went to keep vid.com by the way,
if there's anything that you
can find on the Internet,
like a youtube clip that like,
oh shit,
what if they find out about
this is going to get yanked,
go to keep vid.com keep k,
k e P v I d.com and there's a,
an application.
What it lets you do is you,
you put in the URL of the youtube clip
and then all you have to do is press a,
uh,
you know,
follow the instructions and pick what
resolution you want and what format and
you can download it.
Yeah. And if you have Mac, I've
noticed it doesn't work on chrome. Yes.
It doesn't work on safari
either. I think it works on
Firefox. Safari doesn't work on me,
I just take them off. It doesn't work on
chrome though at all. For some reason.
Maybe I've got it set up wrong, but, uh, I
don't, I'm not a fan of chrome. I use it,
but it shows too many distortions on
websites and I have been going back and
forth. I've, I'm still stuck
with chrome for some reason.
I think it's better than safari.
My problem with safari is that
flash does not work good in safari.
Like I don't know if
that's flash versus apple,
but it seems like safari flash crashes
way more than it does in chrome. Um,
you know,
why is it embarrassing to them that they
didn't know what the Internet was in
1994?
What the fuck is why?
Why does everyone have to look like they
knew everything all the time? I mean,
that's the only one.
Anybody should be upset at that,
that NBC should be fascinated by,
that. They should put that online.
They should put that on the today show
today. Look at us like a fun clip.
Should look at us.
Look at us from,
and if there's two 17 years ago released
a statement like, and just said,
look at this. Wasn't this funny back then
the Internet was in its infancy. Yeah.
You know, and then people would
be like, wow, that's crazy.
Instead they're trying to hush.
It makes you think there needs
to be something to be hushed,
which makes you think that these guys
are dummies when really they would been
like any of them. Exactly.
They're ashamed of themselves,
which is what Charlie Sheen is the
baddest motherfucker on the planet.
Cause he ain't, he ain't ashamed.
Hey, any apologies. He's weird.
Fake mustaches and pick it up.
Hookers. Fucking Bryant Gumbel.
You Pussy. Is it you? Are you?
Are you scared Bryant? Yes.
You scared of everybody knowing that
you didn't know what the Internet was.
I bet that's what it is. I met Brian
Campbell is in alone in his office.
All delusional. Detach from
society going, who put this online?
I'd want his job. You
know, he's not on his job.
You know he's not on the unit level.
Yeah.
He's one of those guys that
refuses to go in the Internet.
I don't think you're right. No, I
think everyone's on the Internet now.
If you want to be a journalist,
there's not a chance in hell you can
stay off the Internet and stay active.
My Stepdad, who is a porn
will architect, nothing else.
My stepdad had come cut a ton of
fat white broad's on his computer.
I bet that's all it is. Fat, greasy, white
bitches eaten chicken. Big Black guys.
Could you imagine how bad ass it would
be if you got to Brian crumbles and all
of his shit was like dudes with bones
in their noses and giant Afros and just
the black cause he's the
whitest black guy ever, right?
The just the blackest of the black.
All just fucking these greasy fat zit
asked white bitches just trailer pitches
with dirty socks on and shit. Just, yeah,
I would love to find
out what kind of porn,
Brian Collins Collins fucking
computer. They do. You Go,
you go to one of these shows like the AVN
and you see these sites and it's like,
how do you even come up with that
exactly what they do. It's also strange,
isn't it man? It's also strange
for people get into, but it's,
this is disturbing to me that
someone lost their job for that.
I should have been given a
raise, you know, or at least
recognize for, as you know,
for Lao. Just found this. That's
amazing. That's a good job. Yeah.
And people are gonna eat up.
I would be laughing if house Brian come,
I would be asking you to play that.
I'd be like play that Jesus kept crook.
And if you imagine what
has changed in 17 years,
cause it's like there's nothing
embarrassing about not knowing that then,
you know,
in 1994 there's nothing embarrassing about
Bryant Gumbel or the the other chick.
No,
you should hear about this
story and fucking write the
producers of that show or
NBC goes, look, do not fire
this guy. Give him his job back.
Stopping a fucking retard. Yes,
absolutely. I 100% agree. Yeah,
that's a very good point Brian.
Yeah. This, this is ridiculous.
If someone lost their job for them,
you know, I heard a, I
heard a story about the uh,
the kind of the father of the
modern computer. This guy,
Alan Turing was a British guy and he
basically developed what was going to be
the groundwork for the binary system.
They know the ones in Zeros and a
brilliant guy created like the touring con
computing system or whatever.
And also actually helped, uh,
help the allied forces decode the codes
that we're going to the u boats from the
Nazis. Why? And I created the
system that help, help do that.
But the fucked up thing was, and what
caught my attention is it's like 1952, um,
he got,
he got a convicted of gross indecency by
the UK cause he was a gay man and they,
the, the punishment at that point
was injections of female hormones.
So they started injecting this dude,
whoa forcibly with female hormones.
Wait a minute,
that's the punishment for gross indecency.
And he committed suicide two years
later, like tragedy. He was only like,
I think he was under 50 years old.
Wow. What is wrong with that?
I knew English folks back
then. Raise that. You would,
that would be the punishment. And this
was like what year was this? It was a two.
I think he died. Yeah, 52. Alan Turing.
T. U. R. I. N. G. You can read this.
Incredible. It is. So what were they
trying to do? Turning into a woman?
I guess it was supposed
to lower his sex drive.
So he wouldn't be humping dudes because
he had too much excess estrogen and
whatever else they put in them.
Who the fuck do you imagine the horror
of like getting state injected female
hormones, which just made you feel all
fucking tracked? Oh my God, terrible.
She just crying after he helped. He
helped decode the fucking codes for the u,
but he should have been given, you know,
here's 20 boys to men do adore you.
You know, like there's a bunch of
dudes like, where's the fucking honor?
It's a nice helping much
things which launched in 70
years, 60 70 years. You know,
it's really kind of crazy
when you think about it.
You know how much more things are accepted
now and that is a direct result of
the spread of information.
Yup.
People kind of understand the gay people
aren't twisted and fucked up and you
know, it's like the ignorance
is the real issue. There's a,
a crazy store that I read today,
um, from God, I forget where it was.
I think it might've been Florida,
I forget the state,
but a guy stabbed his friend because he
found out his friend was a Muslim and
they apparently lived in the same town,
hung out together a bunch of times.
They were talking in their 50s okay,
they're at a bar,
they're talking in a bar and the guy
mentions that he's Muslim and so the other
guy just fucking stabs him in the neck.
She says, yeah, and he gets arrested.
He's like,
Muslims are the causes of problems with
this whole world and I don't like what
you just stabbed that guy in the neck
because he said it was a Muslim like
faggotry
where this association with just
the grip on reality. Some people,
you know the amazing thing though really,
and this is something to focus on,
this is something that's
actually very important.
We are not supposed to know about that
guy because he is fucking nowhere near
us.
The real issue with human beings is
that we're set up to deal with immediate
danger,
immediate threats,
immediate positive and negative aspects
of our life right here and now what's
here. But now because of the Internet and
because of television and the news and
movies, we have access to this fucking
massive chain of shit that's coming in.
So we're not learning about 300 million
people even we're learning about
billions. The whole world
over. The more fucked up it is,
the more you're going to hear about it,
right? You know serial killers and Russia,
fucking guy who eats babies and you
go Slavia where the fuck is happening
completely unrelated to you.
It's all just going to come swarming
NIH to the point where you'll have your
fucking completely terrified.
But if you really look at it,
as long as you don't live in the
shittiest of Shitty neighborhoods,
if you really look at it, it's amazing
how well people get along, right?
It really is quite amazing if you
really stop and think about it,
that we can get through 30 40 years of
a life and never been in a fist fight.
I know a lot of guys who have never been
in funeral benefits plant right into
two, but they were middle school and the
middle is freshmen. It's amazing lived.
I mean,
I've lived a life around a lot of that
and it was only two years ago that I got
in my first actual street fist fight.
Well, I mean if you go to bars,
it can happen. It can happen, but
it's amazing. No, it's hilarious.
It's incredible how rare it
happens. Even at UFC, I mean,
how many times you've been to UFC though?
The audience is drunk.
It's at least 10% skulled tee
shirt wearing meatheads. Right.
At least 10% and still very few fights.
But that is another factor at work there.
If you find someone at a
UFC, you're never know. Yeah.
Someone from American top team who
hasn't made it to TV, Cincinnati,
you're wearing that same teacher.
Check his ears, homie. Yeah, exactly.
That's not a malice living inside of here.
It's a little risky w yeah,
that's true. But there's also, you know,
dudes think through the Falcon. Oh,
of course. The folk in man, of course.
Can't believe Rashad Evans pulled out
that photoed pushy like guys are like,
you know,
send me Twitter messages or email messages
called fighters pussies and I'll just
go, oh my God, y'all silly. This is like,
this is like a little baby crying
right now. This is just nonsense.
You're saying nonsense. You tell me a
professional cage fighter is a pussy.
Even the worst professional
cage fighter is not a pussy.
The worst one that's ever lived,
he's not a pussy. All right.
Even if he fucking taps out after
he gets hit a bunch of times,
you would tap out quicker. Stupid.
Right? All right, let's not, let's go.
No praying. Oh God, no food.
People love to make up shit.
I was reading up all the shit
that Steven Seagal is made up.
I'll throw his career cause there's a
whole thing going on right now where
Steven Seagal told everyone that Anderson
Silva, he taught Anderson that case.
Right? Which is kind of what
he's supposed to do, right?
I mean he's this videos of him training
with the Anderson will fucking Anderson
who barely speaks English.
They just run around and tell
everybody that you taught them it.
And you know what Anderson so cool.
He'll probably be like, yeah, yeah,
he taught me he's a good guy. People
thought that was just him playing at goop.
But Anderson Anderson might,
people do a little wing Chung and the,
and he always does that.
He'll do a little like moving the hands
funny and he's just letting you know
he's ready to fucking explode in your
face to kick you in the chin. Yeah.
That was ridiculous. Was
ridiculous. Really saying that.
Is He really saying that he's
the one that taught him? Yeah.
Steven's Goldsboro send their boss route
and went fucking crazy and boss route.
I'm going to go do an
advertisement for his gem,
so I'm gonna try to get
him on the podcast too.
Cause Pos Rutan we'll have some fucking
amazing stories of brawls and Holland.
He's just a savage.
I love boss ruin,
but Pasc went crazy on Twitter and he's
like, you know what planet is he from?
Did he learn this from fucking Disneyland?
He's like,
boss roots go crazy on Twitter.
Is that he's angry at Steven.
I heard all hired an
unverified story about, uh,
when gene labelle and Steven Seagal
had on, yeah, that's true story.
That's an absolute true story.
[inaudible] the bell told me that story.
Jean Jean tells you it like this.
He doesn't actually tell you
those stories and wow. You know,
Steven was trying to say that
no one could choke 'em out.
You can't choke them out.
He had this move,
this move or stop you from choking out.
So, you know, I got all right Steve,
let's try it. And I get
him in. I had locked there,
I get them in the rear naked and uh,
he takes this hand,
the free hand in and you cherish
karate chops me. Right. And you know,
the old sisters and there's like, you
know, the way genial bell talks about,
I wouldn't even say, as Paul
says, the nicest guy ever.
He would say stuff like right in the
old Johnson, you know, and then a while.
And then I guess he got tired after doing
that and he just fell asleep, I guess.
Uh, maybe forgot to go to the bathroom.
So I went to the bathroom then
it'd be no gene Lebell. Sheila
Bell is like, first of all,
he was like one of the
original mixed martial artists.
He's a judo guy that had cage fights or it
wasn't a cage. It was, uh, you know, um,
uh, uh, basically a mixed rules fight
where he fought a boxer, you know,
he fought a boxer with his judogi on and
just took the boxer down and beat his
ass. You know, gene was like,
he's like the guy that taught Bruce
Lee about grappling, you know,
Bruce Lee back in the day thought you
could just karate kick everybody in the
head. And that would, that
was the shit, you know.
And Bruce Lee actually worked on a lot
of like more effective things like leg
kicks and short range techniques,
wing Chung and boxing
punches and stuff like that.
But he really wasn't aware about grappling
until he hooked up with Jean Labelle
and Jean lapels, a fucking
gorilla. He should just, you know,
national champion judo player. And he's
just so fucking ridiculously strong.
And I'm sure he grabbed that little hunt
and tidy for 35 bell Chinese man had a
fucking shit his pants going. Okay, now
we learn crappola you know what I mean?
He has had to learn grappling after you
fucked around with gene labelle. Yeah.
So Gina Bell telling the story, you
know, it makes it extra funny. But,
but he was at the UFC again. He's in,
in uh, into Anderson Silva's corner. Oh,
nice. He's always a Steven Seagal is
always an Anderson Silva supposedly.
I don't know. How did they, how
did they get together? They made,
it's just like a fan and you
wanted to tell you what dude,
the bottom line is whatever you think
might think silly above Steven Seagal.
The mother motherfucker was
a serious Iko guy. You know,
like if you watch is that Quito videos?
He's not completely full of shit.
All right. I'm not a fan of Ikea.
I think it's silly nonsense.
But if you're going to get good at
silly nonsense with the [inaudible],
which I kind of did, I got
really good at taekwondo. Right.
And a lot of that silly nonsense lie,
that shit doesn't work when dudes are
shooting doubles on you and trop elbows at
your face, Steven Seagal are and the
different kind of silly nonsense.
And it's not all silly nonsense.
It's just that out of all of it,
what percentage of it would actually
work against someone knew what the fuck
they're doing. That's the most
important thing about martial arts.
It's got to work on someone who
knows how to fight. Right. You know,
like you always talk to those street
fight guys like we brought you the street
tempo. We work on street Campbell,
basically a lot of techniques, um,
involving a mailboxes, whatever
you're finding the street. Yeah.
You know how to slam a
guy into a news reader.
It's like they'll have like fucking
techniques. So will you take your keys,
you put them in between your non,
now you essentially have a deadly weapon
in your hand and they're like your keys
or poking out.
Like how long does it take to get your
fucking keys and stick your knuckles in
them and hold them. Get the fuck out
of here. If you're getting in a fight,
do you really want to
puncture someone's throat?
Sounds like something that you would get
your tight at. Rates School. You know,
you don't get raped ladies. Put your
keys down. Yeah, that stuff. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Those,
those rape classes or do you ever seen
that when they put the guy puts on the
big blue suit and the wind scream no.
And just kick them and kicking is the
mind lie on your back and learn how to
kick. Learn how to use a
guard. Learn how to put a desk.
If a woman wants to learn how to fight,
you should learn Jujitsu.
Cause the reality is it's a very rare,
unless you're like an
exceptionally strong women,
like I've met some women that have like
good bone structure that's strong and
you're like, wow, this chick
punches. She could fucking hurt you.
Like one of the dudes who work for um,
a fear factor had an assistant and
she was just like, uh, you know,
corn fed girl just fucking not fat at all.
She was like only 130 pounds,
but this bitch could punch so hard. It
was ridiculous. She, she like told me,
she was like, I could punch
really hard. I'm like, okay,
I get my hand and she hit my hand.
I want damn.
And I thought about like her
punching me in the face. I'm like,
this is what you might be a little,
knock me out if she sucker punched me.
Like she fucking hits hard, get
out, get caught. You never know.
Most girls can't do it. Most girls don't
know how to punch that heart. It's,
it's a rare thing. So for most girls,
if they want to learn how to fight,
they're gonna learn how to use
their legs and learn how to grapple.
Because if you learn Jujitsu,
you could really mobilize someone who is
much stronger than you just with 10 it
seems like a, a good triangle choke
should be a mandatory hard to do.
If a guy knows,
I mean,
if a guy knows how to fight your
phone or in a rape scenario, yeah,
but at least he can eat your gun. Hold
on. Be In guard anyways. Right? Yeah.
You know, I mean, I suppose there's a
good chance they could slap that on.
He's got to know what was going on,
you know,
and choke him out cold on his fucking leg.
Make sure it doesn't slam me. But yeah,
you have to, um, you know,
you have to learn how to use your legs
because your legs are what's carrying you
around all day. You know,
for a woman, her arms,
you don't even realize what
percentage is weak or your arms are,
and that's what your weapons are.
You thinking about hitting
someone with your hands? Yeah.
What are your hands doing all day?
They ain't doing shit, but Karen,
your purse and fingering yourself, right?
That's not a lot of energy expended.
All right? You don't mean what
your legs are carrying 150, 130,
whatever the fuck you way they're
carrying that around all day.
You'd legs are ridiculously strong.
It's like an ostrich. You know,
you get ahold of the ostrich wing,
what does that going to do it they
don't even work. They don't do,
but they'll kick a fucking
hole in your chest. Yeah,
those big meaty ostrich thighs. Those are
crumb looking. Remember our Crum, the uh,
you know our chrome is a
comic book artist. Yeah.
I used to draw these women with those
big giant ostrich asses. Awesome.
He said what a weird movie that crumb
movie. Yeah. That's fascinating man.
Fascinating. Anyway, did you watch
the Super Bowl? Of course not.
I don't give a fuck about football. Did
you sleep? I didn't even know who won.
I didn't,
not only did I not know who won,
I didn't even know who was in it until
after it was over. I had no idea.
I am completely blissfully unaware
of football. I don't get it.
But what I did get was that Christina
Aguilar a fuck up on the national anthem.
Oh, I love when someone fucks up. I
don't know why. And look, if it was me,
I'd be embarrassed too.
But there's something about every one
of us that loves when someone fucking
chunks. How do you act like I know
nerds and stuff that you're a singer,
so how do you fuck up the one song
that everybody knows you're ready?
Yeah, she's fat. Oh, that's why.
Can't look forward to the next thing. You
have hamburgers. The first one. Listen,
bitch, you ain't tricking anybody by
wearing black and ain't dark out. Okay.
We see a large black object I screen.
You know she's thinking Baconator
Baconator Baconator what are you doing?
I understand divorce is hard on
everybody, sweetie. That's good.
But you've got like $1 billion and you
need to hire a fucking trainer. Okay.
Eats of vegetables every now and then.
Now,
did she fuck up once or twice or did she,
I don't know the words,
the national anthem, but it was
definitely wrong. All right. Just listen,
listen to listen to it.
She apparently fucked up the lyrics and
switched it around and repeated lyrics
in some shit.
Yup.
Unlike just you could look over and see
football players in the audience and
they were mouthing, I think she
fucked up. They're like mouth thing.
I think she fucked that up to a
higher America. Wrapping Award.
Witnessing to this guy's
fake voice. Acular off. Okay.
I should be at a strip club in
Ohio coming to the Stephen King.
Yeah,
you'd be the king of Oscar.
[inaudible] you.
Hey [inaudible]
word.
Yay.
[inaudible]
who rose? No, this is still okay.
Garage [inaudible] script.
Woo.
Hooray.
Locked up for the ramparts we watched
[inaudible]
oh, she fucked up. She, she said that
twice. Oh my gosh. She
fucked up hard dude.
[inaudible]
yeah,
she just fucked up that part.
She repeated herself twice.
[inaudible]
you gotta think about the song,
I mean, this is talking about
bombs going off in this guy.
Sorry.
I'd rather we're such cocksuckers.
I always say the United States
is the balls of the Dick.
That's fucking the world. That's what
we are as citizens in this crazy,
ridiculous rocket shooting
rockets at our own lyrics.
The national anthem has rockets and bombs
and we are fighting for freedom though.
Talking about the glare of rockets.
Red Glare,
red glare of rockets like so many
rockets that changed the night.
You already did that one did
it twice, Fella. You did that.
How sad is that? Did that poor girl
fucked up like that. That's pretty rough.
Do people realize it too?
But they still cheered.
I wonder if she got off going on. If
anybody know, if anybody knew. Well,
I think how her style of singing or like,
I couldn't even understand
what she was like, well,
why don't I knew Ron so much that I
think, I don't know. I love singing sucks.
Yeah.
I don't like it where they're changing.
I mean pit random like what
you like. It's okay. You know?
I'm not saying that I'm right and you're
wrong. I'm saying is I think it sucks.
I don't like it. Yeah. I think that,
uh, that style is I, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like you just show him what
you can do with your voice, right?
Like what does that girl named Natalie?
A what the fuck's her name is singer.
Uh, God dammit, I need to talk.
She's got a beautiful, yes, Nicole.
She dumb. I'll look it up on iTunes right
here. She does it, but when she does it,
she does it like it's like she's
not doing it like, like to try to,
just to try to make the,
hearing her voice sound differently.
She's expressing herself a certain way.
I think you should think about the
words of the song and what your end,
if it accentuates the message of
the song then Dylan, Nelly Furtado,
that's her name. Yeah. Like
put on that song. I'm like a
bird. Put it on. Just do it.
Gives a shit.
It's fucking fuck serious.
I want to hear this God damn song cause
it's interesting we have to edit this
out. I'm sure they have some
sort of intern system to get,
find someone who can go,
hey dude,
there's some songs up in this
bitch once you go find them. Yeah.
But my point is that there's a difference
between someone who's got a beautiful
voice and someone's got a beautiful
voice and they have to fucking show for
buddy.
You know,
it's like a Dude Who's a
all oiled up wearing a tank
top and walking around town.
So like, all right, dude, I know you work
out. Okay. It's 30 degrees out. Well,
I got a tank top on it. Okay. Can you
fucking dummy with your stupid voice?
Yeah,
you got something there. What do you
got today? You would think that someone,
you know,
it's like a Steven Pressfield in the war
of art talking about professionals and
not professionals, but not
professional thing to do. Absolutely.
Just have to overdo something to show
what you're capable of. You know?
It's like fashion should show up, do
the job, do it as good as you can.
And it's like somebody wants their
guitar solo in no matter what,
even if the song. All right. All right.
And there's a lot of that out there
because there's the guitar Solos.
What gets you all that sweet pussy?
It's just me. There's a spotlight on
me. I had that guitar and I just feel
it like this and this girl's voices.
This girl has a gorgeous voice.
Yeah,
she's a pretty girl. And when she
sings though, like you can you,
you know that she's got
this incredible range,
but she's not using it to be a Douche.
She's using it like she's
trying to make the songwriter
turned out fine.
Okay.
God, man, that's
beautiful. Listen to this.
[inaudible] mom and baby [inaudible].
She sees bird
thinking about a burden.
You don't understand.
It's real man.
It's,
it's not just flashy showbizzy horse shit.
And then once she does that, you know, she
stretches it out, but it makes sense. No,
there's fucking professional.
Are you listening, Christina?
Put the fucking donuts down and go
running. I'm going to get this together.
Hooker. It's not too
late. It's not too late.
What do you 30 okay. Pull it
together. Whore. I'll date. Yeah.
Brian will fuck up your life
more than food ever could.
And I could look like you're Jewish.
You will be so stressed out.
You will lose massive amounts of weight.
I shouldn't have called her a whore that
was searching for a word. That's right.
I meant hooker, but I'd already said it.
I bet she's awesome to hang out with.
We call check hooker and it's okay. I like
shut up hooker, he just playing around.
But you say shut up whore and you're
like, Hey, what are you doing? Hookers?
Like a funny word,
but it's for the fucking same thing.
I girls call each other hook here all
the time. And it's funny, you know I,
I would call, he's always calling
people hooker like in the audience too.
Like someone yells in, I'm like,
shut up poker. Sit the fuck.
But it doesn't really mean whore. You
know, it means like freak bitch, you know,
like sit the fuck down. You
whack your broad, you know,
you know what I mean? Right.
But whore. So I Apologize Christina,
don't let me make you eat more.
Don't let me make you run to that fucking
cupboard and start pulling out cookies.
And if you listen this podcast and you
probably don't, let's be realistic,
but you never know man. Never now. I mean
it is on the Internet, but if you listen,
we're just fucking around,
right? And don't get upset,
but it couldn't be funny if it wasn't
true. Okay, we're going to deal,
we all got to deal with our own
little shortcomings in this life.
And you like food, you don't like to work
out. We need to fucking rotate. Those,
need to rotate those secrets. What's, uh,
what's your new business to about? It's,
it's open now. Right? Last time you
were on here, it wasn't open to,
you're talking about, it was just
about to start. So what is it?
So I basically took, um, a
need that I had, you know,
I'm a guy who parties hard, works
hard, works out hard and um,
[inaudible] you don't
always sleep and you know,
like on most people's counter, you
know, I just saw your counter Joe.
There's tons of supplements like a ton.
Like you have to take a bunch
of different stuff. Yeah.
Turn it off and put it all
together. So what I created was, um,
basically a conglomeration of the best
combination of ingredients I could and
put it in two pills,
two different types of formulas.
So one formula as an antioxidant vitality
formula gives you a ton of energy
without the caffeine, which further
dehydrates you, causes bad shit.
And your body and starts eliminating
the free radicals that are coming in.
So you actually feel good and have
more energy as you're going out. Um,
the other one. And so that's for
like during a party or pre party.
It's actually super good
for working out too. Um,
cause it just makes you feel better
and it doesn't get you all wired.
That's the day dayquil. Yeah,
that's basically all it's
called Rolando. Rolando.
And what's the name of your company on it?
Labs. And it was on@labs.com on it.com.
O n n I t. Dot. Go. And the other
ones for the learning it. O N N,
double n O. U. Oh, that's
confusing. Who's o? N I T.
I dunno. Some mother fuckers
owning your business, man.
So that's something we need to get
another website. That ain't gonna work.
It's gonna fuck people up.
Double. That double ends a mess.
That's going to remember you're gonna,
you're gonna lose money from that double
line. Did you try to do, to try on it?
labs.com, uh, with one
end? I liked the devil.
Well because I don't want it to be too
literal, you know, like on it, you just,
it's just the [inaudible] was
like Yahoo money. I hate money,
but so then there's like a Jewish manager
money, Charles, if you hate money.
So I manage her, says, oh, well we
did this, uh, the show and um, uh,
in Vegas this weekend and uh,
well I shouldn't even talk about this.
He's going to get mad if I talk about
that. What? I can't say anything. Oh,
I gotta I gotta pull out
on it labs. So N, N I t,
so it's [inaudible] dot com and all
this stuff's available right now for
[inaudible]. So shit that kills hangovers
should that while, yes, and the recovery
formula is more focused on your
brain because if you're not sleeping,
if you're partying, doing anything, you're
not restoring your Serotonin, oxytocin,
dopamine, and all of the brain chemicals
get restored during deep sleep.
If you're boozed up or if
your party and your case,
your store those with pills or just
help it a little bit, you can help.
You can help it quite a bit because a
five HTP is the building direct precursor
to Serotonin and when combined with B
six which is the catalyst which converts
five HTP to Serotonin, you can actually
start rebuilding serotonin way faster.
Otherwise it would take weeks to rebuild
but going blast out your serotonin.
You have the five HTP with the vitamin B,
six pyridoxine,
then you can actually recover
your serotonin faster.
So that's why people feel bummed out after
having slept and are they get cranky.
This would be perfect for like
if you're dancing with Molly
prophetically, if you were doing
ecstasy or do some kind of drug,
that'd be perfect for that.
Right. Dancing with Molly,
you talking about there's a type
of exercise in called Molly, right?
Pure fat and yeah,
I mean obviously the product would work
extremely well for that because not only
is it restoring your Serotonin,
which is actually what makes you feel
good is the ecstasy releases too much
serotonin in your body.
Also,
the other formulas are going to start
mitigating the neuro toxicity associated
with keeping your body at that kind of
high level of reverberation where all
your ht transmitters are just all blocked
up and the Serotonin is running wild.
It makes me feel great, but it's doing
some, it's doing a little bit of damage,
not like the, the f you know, like the
studies that said it fries your brain.
What is,
what does it do?
Like the studies that say that
ecstasy was called regrained. Yeah,
those were actually, it was mixed
with methamphetamines. Okay.
So it was a bad sample that they
were using and methamphetamines,
does that show up in your brain? Well,
that's a kind of a metaphorical way,
but it does serious, serious damage. Um,
you know, ecstasy from what you know,
there's actually a big study by Rick
Strassman now on post traumatic stress for
Mtma. Really? And Yeah.
Soldiers coming back from the
war, they're all tweaked out.
They can't trust anything.
They're shaken and bombs are going off
in their head when they hear something
slam on a table. The MVMA, well pure
Mgma, I shouldn't call it ecstasy,
that's kind of the street name
for the drug, but the pure Mbma,
it creates an environment where you're
trusting and loving of the universe again.
And so they're able to go relive
some of these things and say, okay,
that was war. But you know what?
This isn't more like this is,
this is life and life is good.
There's beauty in this life.
And really with some of the
studies coming back, they just did,
I think a 20 person study got
the results done through maps,
maps.org and a great,
which is the center for
psychedelic studies running
at what does map stand for?
Mol Multidisciplinary,
something like studies
and Multidisciplinary
Association, Psycho study,
something like that. Um, but yeah,
great study that came back. But,
but what ecstasy we'll do is
obviously it's very dehydrating.
So you don't wouldn't want to take any
caffeine or anything like that because
your body's trying to get rid of
it. Uh, just like any drug you take,
your body's trying to do that.
And when your body is trying to get
rid of something, you get dehydrated.
It's also has some neuro
toxicity associated.
Mean if you're going to be in that level
of high reverberation, free radicals,
they're gonna just going to be peeling
out of your body. So really? Yeah. Yeah.
I mean that's what, it's that stress.
It's that kind of stress that's,
that's causing, you know, you learn
all this stuff. Did some research,
did some research on it.
You know,
I mean obviously the psychedelic
research and a lot of this is,
is up my alley plus with the supplements,
just dealing with the formulas
that I have and seeing kind of the,
the damage did,
a lot of people in my generation are going
through who are partying hard and you
know, some of them are doing
drugs. I'm not advocating doing it,
but a lot of people are doing it and
they're doing it in a way that's really
damaging their ability to move
on with their life and you know,
handle business as well as
they should. So, you know,
while these forms aren't
designed specifically for that,
they do obviously really
help because it's just like,
that's like the ultimate level of,
of putting a tax on your body.
You're partying with drugs, it's like
takes it to the other levels. So,
so the rollover formula has
five HTP directly converts
to Serotonin, Tryptophan,
which is actually the
building block of five HTP.
So it's more like a time release. Also
at the same thing. It's in thanksgiving.
Turkey makes you kind of sleepy,
kind of brings you down from any
of your big high experiences.
I lived in ecstasy once and I
decided right after I did it.
This is probably not a good thing to
do. Yeah, I felt terrible the next day.
You need the recovery for me,
right? I need the whole block.
There's a couple things happening.
You have neuro toxicity built up and
you have low serotonin from Watson,
from what's happened. So, um, you know,
it can make you feel, yeah, totally.
I want to try this stuff too. Um,
I think it's fascinating. This a,
there's a whole new area of,
um,
interest these days and that's a mind
chemicals like mind vitamins would they
call nootropics a bunch of
different substances that
Incruse Cree circulation to
certain areas of the brain increase
the workload workload rather of certain
areas. I'd love that stuff. I
think it's so, so amazing. Yeah.
So that people have figured out
how to do that. You know, it's,
it's really amazing how many different
substances on this earth interact with
the human body.
Like I gave you guys some Stevia.
We have coffee here and instead of
sugar we have Stevia. And Stevia is,
it's like this natural sweetener that
doesn't have any calories and it doesn't
fuck you up and it doesn't. Yep. Jack,
your glucose levels are, it's really,
yeah. It's really good. Yeah. Dissolves
in, dissolves in a cup of green tea that,
yeah. Yeah. And it's, uh, it's,
it's interesting, you know,
that there's all these different
things like caffeine, you know,
there's things that jack up your, you
know, your chemistry and get you going.
Like it's amazing how
many different things are.
And what's also very interesting is that
the lobbies that try and block these
things.
Yeah.
Yeah. You know, I don't
know that my facts exactly,
but I know that the sugar lobby
put up a big stink about Stevia,
like a big stink, I'm sure
created some, created some issues.
Like I don't think like Coca Cola
and other countries, diet coke,
he uses Stevia, but in
really mess. Yeah. Um,
coke 99% sure that coke uses Steven.
I know there are some sodas that use it.
I definitely, but then,
but they don't use it here.
The U s just because there's
such a stink about it.
You know what the Hillary
Clinton lobby's done.
Hillary Clinton was asked yesterday about,
let me find the article so I can, uh,
cause it's so ridiculous. It just shows
what the fuck is wrong with this country.
Yeah.
Mexican Coca Cola is in bottle.
You can buy out in La and they use
real cane sugar is still in Mexico.
So we you have like a coke in the bottle
out front and here in la it's so weird
tasting quick cause it kinda remember
you kind of remember as a kid drinking
like here's what I'm,
here's what Hillary Clinton said.
They were talking to her about the war
in Mexico and drugs and this just goes to
show you how fucked up the drug
lobbyist in this country are in the
pharmaceutical lobbyists and
how much influence they have.
We can't legalize drugs because
there's just too much money in it.
That's what she said. This
is an exact quote. You know,
I hate to say a debate. I hear it in
my country, it's not likely to work.
There's just too much money in it.
I don't think that you can legalize
small amounts for possession,
but those who are making so much money
selling, they have to be stopped.
Oh you mean like pharmaceutical
companies pushing Oxycontin's in Florida?
Like they're fucking kit kats. Is
that what you mean? It's so dirty.
How they do it too. Like even El
Tryptophan, Tryptophan is, you know,
it's going to boost your serotonin.
A lot of those drugs, Prozac, Paxil,
all these things,
they fall in a category called Ssri,
selective Serotonin reuptake inhibitors,
and all of those drugs are basically
operating on your serotonin mechanism,
giving you more serotonin. Well,
Tryptophan five HTP does is naturally,
they gives one bad batch of Al Tryptophan
that came in from Japan. I was tainted.
It had some bacteria that grew in it,
like it could happen to fucking vitamin C,
whatever.
They logged on to that and just started
pounding the FDA and the FDA outlawed it
for like 10 12 years until finally
people were like, this is ridiculous.
Stuff helps you relax, helps
you sleep, build serotonin.
But the drug lobbies have just huge power.
You know what I mean?
Huge power to be able to alter.
It's incredible that she
would have answered this
that way without the obvious.
But obviously there's a lot of other
drugs that are legal in this country,
like alcohol and tobacco. The
cause a lot of damage. I mean,
they don't even look at the whole
picture when they're answering.
They're so used to people not
completely questioning them.
You're right there fellow. Yeah, there's
something going on with their mix.
They started echoing or something.
It there's, there's, there's some,
there's an arrogance to these type
of answers. You know, that you're,
you're supposed to be the person with
the answers. Someone asks you a question,
here's your answer.
And you know,
logically that this answer is ridiculous
because it discounts all the money that
you get from drug companies,
from pharmaceutical companies.
What about all the money you get from
alcohol companies and tobacco companies
would know. What about all that
money? Where, where is that? Would it,
how does that factor into
your thing? Well, it doesn't,
they just stopped the conversation
and it's like, it's, it's a sickness.
It's a sickness that we allowed this.
It's a sickness that politicians can say
retarded shit like that and not just be
blasted all over the newest
were being hypocrites. I mean,
what they should have on CNN
tonight is Hillary Clinton's quote.
And then all the fucking money she got
when she was running for how much of it
is connected
to pharmaceutical companies and how
much of it was connected to alcohol
companies and back or yeah. How much
where's the lobbyists were, were,
who's paying them? Well, you know,
what is she voted for in the past?
What does she tried to keep legal, you
know, come on man, you fucking criminals.
You dirty, stinky, corrupt
criminals. Every one of you fucks.
I'm trying not screaming in the streets.
You're a fucking crook.
I've gotten pretty fired up on
the same topic recently. And um,
I just got a found a video from
Milton Friedman who is a pretty famous
libertarian and economist. Um,
and he was actually talking,
it's just a real breath of fresh air to
listen to him cause he's quoting John
Stuart Mill, the philosopher
basically saying like, the only right,
the government has to impose on our
freedom is if we're hurting somebody else.
Like yeah, the bottom line period.
Like no other, no other statements.
And the video that actually
have on my site is,
is a Milton Friedman talking about
seatbelt and helmet laws and he's saying,
I mean he's saying like
this was a litmus test,
the seatbelt and helmet laws of the
government imposing their will upon people
and nobody really cares that much about
those laws. But he's like, this is,
this is a sign of what they're doing.
They're saying they know better than you,
what's good for you and they're
going to make you do this. He said,
it's your fully your right to where it
should be full of your right to wear it.
No helmet on your, on your motorcycle.
Like it's not going to hurt anybody else.
Yeah, it's a stupid risk.
You shouldn't do it.
It's not advocating wearing no helmets,
but that's your right and the government
has no fucking business right telling
you otherwise.
It's like you telling Ryan that he has
to wear a helmet and if he doesn't,
you're going to lock him in a cage.
Yeah.
No difference between you and
the government. I mean, you know,
other than the fact that supposedly
the government is supposedly elected to
represent you, which gets very
true. Questionable. It's very,
very fucking gross. Yeah. God dammit. But
you know, the, the other point is too,
that if you're, if you create all of
these laws that people find is immoral,
you know,
they begin to distrust the whole system.
Like you have to follow these laws.
Like people don't look at police as they
should. Like police should be saviors,
you know, like, oh, thank God the
police are here. Right? You know,
you're having a party, everybody's happy.
Things are good. You're like, oh fuck,
there's a fucking police outside.
You know,
it's like when you create
a system like that,
that's when things get fucking tracked.
There's a cop in Los Angeles that a claim
to have gotten shot outside of school.
Um, and uh, he was, uh, apparently, uh,
bullshit in the entire time and they went
this massive manhunt looking for this
guy who shot the cop and
he gave a description and
everything white male with a
fucking gray ponytail. You know, you think
it's some crazy biker type character,
right? Turns out it was just
complete fabrication. Scott.
Now what did he shoot himself? I don't
know or didn't invite investigating.
They're investigating. So I don't think
they've made an official statement.
But the official statement is that the
cop has admitted that he lied and said no
one really shot him.
So what the fuck man?
And they apparently cost $500,000 for
this manhunt and that's only what it costs
the state.
Cause I was trapped in that traffic and
it was like an hour and a half, you know,
I'm out of my schedule for the next
right. That's a good point,
right? How many people lost money?
How many deals didn't get closed?
How many things didn't it?
Eventually you're going to be able to have
something in your car just like a lot.
I talk shit on your iPhone where if you're
stuck in traffic and you're going to
be able to press a button and have a
fucking direct conference video call with
people, you know they're going to be right
there looking right at you. You know,
like, so you can have a meeting in your
car. Yeah. It should be now auditions.
Why not man fucking love
having calls in my car, man.
That's the number one reason
why I went to Verizon.
I went to Verizon over 18 t was cause
when I had the iPhone and I fucking drive
around, man, my phone just would cut off
left and right and it would piss me off.
It would drive me nuts. Yeah. I T and t is
bad here. Fucking almost never cuts off,
man. It's amazing. I mean it's, it's
like, it's so much better. It's not,
it's not 20% better, 30% better.
It's like 50 or 60% better. You know,
like 18 t was just cutting out everywhere.
The Verizon might fuck up
every now and then. You know,
he'd go through some weird hilly area
or something where there's no signal
period, but, uh, they,
it just fucking 18 t was brutal and not
my car when I get in and it's got that
Bluetooth thing where it syncs up and
then the voice comes through the speakers.
So he can have some pretty
cool conversations and
you're not taking your hands
off the wheel. It's just like someone's in
the car with you. You know, like you're,
you're having a fun car. It makes driving
so much more interesting by herself,
but fucking 18 teach can't pull it off.
Supposedly Verizon with this new iPhone
is actually a teetering your download
speeds if because they're trying.
That's how they're trying to,
I guess the regulating it. Yeah.
Yeah. What is staggering? Staggering.
Yes. Whatever the word is. If you,
if they find out that you use a lot,
they're going to cut your shit down
and then like you'll have like half the
download speed or whatever.
A fraction of the downloads for you
that you had before. That's unknowing.
It is annoying. We know.
What else is annoying though.
It's a world phone and that they
don't have that part activated. Yeah.
Cause I have a blackberry with Verizon.
I've thought about using the iPhone with,
for Verizon,
but you know the UFC,
I'm always traveling to England
and traveling around the world.
I got to go to Australia in a couple of
weeks. I couldn't deal with, you know,
having no phone over there, that would
annoy the shit out of me, you know?
But they don't have anything.
You
think that,
that they're going to activate it later?
Maybe it's just something that they're
waiting on apple to get, you know,
like the software part put in there
somehow. I don't know what the fuck it is,
man. It's kind of annoying. Yeah, it
seems weird that it's in the phone,
but you can't use it. It makes
no sense at all. Right. Chris,
we can hear your European man.
It's not being as your waterfall.
They put doors on bathrooms for a reason.
What didn't you want to talk,
talk about in Vegas now? Can I tell you
what happened to me in Vegas? Yeah, yeah.
Tell me about the hooker
story. Oops, sorry. Yeah,
I forgot. I forgot that.
That was the whole story.
That was what was funny about it.
I just tell you the story. Anyway,
so we were out. This is what happens. Let
me tell you something. What happens? Um,
we were all drunk and it was three o'clock
in the morning or whatever the fuck
it was.
I'm laying in my hotel room,
conked out and my phone starts
vibrating and it's Brian. Yeah.
And so what happened to me is we all
separated after the bars and we, you know,
went to our separate hotel or
separate elevators or whatever.
So I get in an elevator
and right before it closes,
this girl does like the arm thing that
gets to get in the elevator. So I'm like,
oh hey. She was like this girl that looked
just like Kim Kardashian a little bit.
You'll have some taller than me
fucking wearing a nice dress like tan.
Just look really like rich, I guess.
And just top top of the line shelf.
Girl.
I have to comment real quick,
how many girls say they look like
Kim Kardashian on like Facebook dot.
Look that Kim Carter is that if it's,
don't I look like good. So I uh,
I hit 10 that was on floor 10 and she
hit nine. Then she starts texting and,
and just not paying attention.
I was just looking at her
tits wasn't paying attention.
She the door open and shut and then right
when it was shutting, she goes, Oh fuck.
I miss my floor. And I just
jokingly, because I was so wasted,
I had the balls of this. I jokingly said,
you can crash in my room. And she goes,
she looks at me for like a couple
seconds goes, okay. And then we,
the elevator door opens and I'm like in
shock. I'm like, she's not, you know,
she's fucking with me. I
get out the other, she just
falls me out. I had my door,
my, my room was right down
there, started walking.
She's just falling and we're not talking,
we're not saying anything.
I just look over at her, I'm
smiling, she's like smiling at me.
And then I opened my door up,
the door opens, she shuts,
she fucking immediately throw it,
pushes me against a wall, grabs my dick,
starts making out with me just for like
a good minute or what's going through
your head right at that point? Like, don't
fuck this up. Don't fuck this up. Fuck,
yeah. Fuck yeah, this is awesome.
I'm making out with a girl and then I
have to be on my tippy toes to make out
with, uh, and then she goes thousand
dollars if you want to play.
And I was like, oh your, I
thought you were a real girl
and that true. Yeah, it's going
to bring, when I said, I'm
like, oh, that sounded bad,
but uh, and then she goes, no
honey, no, no. And she goes,
all right, that's cool. Well,
and I'm like, Oh, I'm so sorry. I'm so
sorry. I thought you were just saying,
you know, a real girl. And then she
goes, no problem. And then she goes,
here's one for the road
or something like that.
And then she just started making out
with me again and I'm thinking like,
do I pay her five bucks for that?
And then I'm also thinking,
I'm also thinking like thousand dollar
hooker. That's like top grade hooker.
That's not like a normal Mandalay
bay hooker. Right. That's like a,
that's like Charlie Sheen Hooker.
Right.
It could have easily been her first time
being a hooker and she's just a crazy
bitch. Right? I mean she just couldn't
be crude. So fucking hot though.
I think she was just like high class
one that happened to be just got done
blowing Jay z and,
and you know what's crazy is hurting her
mouth tastes like red bull and socks.
And I remember thinking that like,
like wow, she just drink a red bull.
And she was on a flip there
blowing from there. And then,
and then after that happened
I called Joe and I'm like,
I can't believe this happened.
And then I'm thinking like,
do I like run down the hall and
tell her like, hey, after you work,
if you want to just, you know,
spoon later or something like that,
thinking like all these gay thoughts
cause I'm going to have to do anything and
we can set up the money. But if you
want to hang out, hey, I'm cool.
Oh that's hilarious.
Yeah.
And what's crazy is this a girl
that I'm dating here and there like,
but when it came back, I'm like making
out with her and she goes, she goes,
all right, so you didn't kiss anyone but
that hooker this weekend. Right. And like
that's worse. I'm like,
well, I could kiss five
miscellaneous girls, but I kiss one
hooker. That's fine. You're [inaudible].
You're okay with that
because of the story's funny.
Don't complain. Just accepted
universally. Don't complain.
Vegas was fucking awesome. Thank you to
everybody who came out show sold out.
Awesome. Giant theater
to Mandalay. Big Theater.
This is the biggest place I've ever
done in Vegas. Who's like 1700 seats.
It was awesome. Yeah, that was cool.
How'd you, how did it feel to be on stage?
Because it seemed like it's,
that's hard to grab a whole theater.
I mean this was like where you see the
play cats. This is not just a theater.
This is a huge theater.
Well it was the lion king.
That's where the lion king's blanking.
Not. They're all the same thing.
Cats like exactly entertaining.
Right? Cats has done.
Everybody realize that cats is a scam.
About five years ago this like,
what the fuck are we watching?
Did girl take me to see cats once when
I was like fucking 19 I was dating this
girl. She took me and I was 19
hours a a wild monkey. All right,
and I was a savage.
I couldn't sit down and watch something
stupid like cats and I sit in,
I don't know,
sitting there and it was an hour and a
half and then it stops and you get an
intermission and I'm like,
get your shit.
There's nowhere where I want to just
get your shit and we're going to go.
We're not going to watch these fucking
people parade around in a cat outfit
isn't terrible show.
It's admirable.
Katz was one of those things that is
just a mind numbing assault on your
attention span. By the time you get
done. If you take a girl to see cats,
by the time you're done,
your self esteem is so low,
you could barely get it up to fucker
because you've just been abused by some
terrible entertainment
and then you finally go,
what the fuck is wrong with her that
she likes this and why am I with her and
what am I doing with my life?
These are the type of people
that I'm hanging out with.
Someone who likes cats like you're,
you're fascinated by these fucking
retards prancing around in giant catsuits.
First of all,
they don't look anything like cats do
those like people with stupid outfits on.
Anyway, the lion king is nothing
like this, like actually exciting.
And we were in the lion king theater.
It's Mandalay Bay theater.
It's where they show the lion king.
But it was huge.
It was a fucking like 1700 seeds
giant fucking room did, did you,
did you feel like you had to change your
style anyway or your time in a bunch of
big rooms before and you know like the
place I do an Edmonton when I do to
Canada, that's more than 2000
people. Plus I did in Calgary.
That was like 2000 people or 1800 people.
Toronto is something where somewhere
around that, the next one we're doing it.
Toronto and tickets are
going to go on sale soon.
I know everybody keeps
asking me about Toronto. Um,
I think they go on sale this Friday,
but it's a theater in Toronto and uh,
it's like 2,500 seats.
So I'll tell you all about that show.
There's a secret link to that.
I just got sent.
I don't know if you're allowed to
tweet that link or if, well, no,
because it's not, they're
not up yet. Right. What's the
name of the theater? Blurry.
It would seem like they're,
the different experience would be
doing like full Colosseum. Yeah. Yeah.
That's almost impossible
to connect with people.
But I feel like you can still connect
with people if there's a, you know,
I think like you can get a couple
thousand people and if they're cool,
everybody good. Have a good
time. And you're still in
the grove though. You know,
you get to like some,
I heard like Larry,
the cable guy does like football stadiums.
He does like 50,000 people since then.
Wrap your head around that shit son.
Just wrap your head around that Massey
Hall in Toronto. That's where it is.
And that'll be on April the 29th. I said
tickets I think go on sale on Friday.
But um, uh, you know, 50,000 people.
He does like the whole fucking football
stadium filled with Larry the cable
again, cable guy fans. That's impossible
to connect to those people. I mean, yeah,
you hope you do you,
you get the people in the front and you
lock eyes with them and keep the party
rolling. But yeah, there's not a lot of
room for ad libbing and fucking around.
Yeah. You know, it's just
here's a show, Bang, Bang, Bang.
You got to bust it out and his is
short and tight in order as possible.
You know the,
the best thing about small clubs,
like we're going to do a sales
comedy hole in La this weekend.
Brian's going to do it to Brian does it
all the time and it's on Melrose real
intimate place. Like when it's filled, I
think it only gets like 70 or 80 people.
Right? They're, they're expanding it.
Yeah. He bought the place really recently.
Sally used to have a place
on labrea. Right. So was it
really another small place,
a fat like a hundred or so.
And what uh,
that he did was he bought a new place and
then with the new place he's expanding
the back area and then it's
going to be like a 300 seater.
But for right now it's like really
small and um, Salah, you know,
he's got this like just,
it's just a sweet set up.
He's like always does open mics
all the time. Every day. Yeah.
It's always like promoting comedy and
trying to get like young comics to,
to really get into it and you know,
and help him out.
One of my friends from South Park,
he's making a movie,
I call it serial comic and a,
it's about a comic that it's like mixed
with Dexter and he's never done standup
comedy. And so I was hanging out with
them last night and he's like, you know,
cause I'm doing this. Maybe I think
I need to know what it feels like.
And so him and the other guy went on
stage and did their first stand up out of
the blue like no material.
And they did good for the first
time with no material just going up.
And I told them like,
just tell a funny story.
Just tell some stories that's happened to
you, you know, and try to do it onstage.
They both did. Now they're,
they're, they're, they're,
they're addicted to it now.
They're like immediately
like fucking first hit.
If you do good man, do good to get
that bug. There's thing, you know,
shit gets crazy. It's weird. There's a
difference in doing a large audience,
but, um, it's not a bad difference.
It's good for a show like a special,
like doing a special,
like I want to do one special at
least where I do it in a comedy club.
Cause the last one I did in
a big theater, I think, um,
when you do a special though, it's
really kind of got to be here. The jokes,
the jokes, not that much fucking around.
Here's the jokes, you know, it's like,
it's not the same as like a,
a live audience.
They appreciate you no more fucking
around and ad libbing. And it's like,
it's like a looser, more open thing.
But in, in transmitting it to a DVD,
it really should be, you
know, the material kind of
as it's written, you know?
So the difference is that if
you're doing a, um, a big theater,
you just don't feel like you have
as much slack. Right. You know,
like when you're in a, like a little
seat, a little, um, a hundred seater,
it's like a little tight, intimate club
feel like you just, there's no pressure.
You know, we're all just fucking
around having a good time,
whereas it's like 2000 people. It's
like, okay, I'm here to do a show.
And they get ramped up. Like
Joey, like Joey came out,
guns blazing crazy.
Joey knew it was a show slaughtered,
slaughtered, or fucking piss. And I fell
down. I fell down laughing. I said that,
you know, I th I told them after
the show, I told a bunch of people,
I think that's the funniest
I've ever seen anybody do.
I don't think I've ever seen
anybody rose to the occasion. Yeah.
15 minutes of just destruction just
went out there and hulk smashed on.
It was pretty bad ass. But um, yeah, Joey
knows how to do those kinds of rooms.
He just goes out there and hits him with
his best shit over and over and over
again, you know? But, uh, the theater
was bad ass. It's fucking really big.
And so we're going to do it again
on July 3rd, I think it is. Yeah.
I think that's what it is. Yeah.
It's whatever the, uh, the next,
there's going to be,
um,
a weekend and whatever
the Friday is July 2nd.
So it's July 1st because July 2nd
is the UFC. It's July 4th weekend,
but July 4th is Monday.
So I'll be there on the first July 1st.
You know, what's kind of show, I don't
know if you guys have ever seen it,
but in the big stadiums,
I talked to a hypnotist actually,
and he was saying the bigger the stadium,
it seems like that'd be hard to do,
like hypnotized someone with all that
pressure. But the bigger the stadium,
like the easier the people go to
sleep. Wow. Somehow. Yeah. Like it's,
it's in versus the opposite. Yeah.
Well I think it's, there's just this,
I don't know. I mean for
whatever reason, I don't know.
I can't deeply delve into the
psychology of it, but somehow that,
that type of environment and
they get these people on stage,
which is unbelievable to me because I
can't imagine being hypnotized personally
myself. Uh, but credible. But
they'll go, they'll go right out.
And then obviously they do all that
kind of, that kind of wacky stuff.
But those shows are pretty
interesting to me that, you know,
they can take somebody in that environment
where they're already nervous and
like, people are watching me holy
Shit and put them right the fuck out.
You know why? Because some
people are weak, right?
Some people are supposed to be like,
well, and then they do short circuit.
Some people are supposed to be led,
do subtly take the people out who aren't
falling asleep and they just go away.
So they start with 12 then with,
you know,
eight. Yeah. It's amazing how
they know, you know, I, uh,
you should do shows back in Boston
with this guy named Frank Santos,
who is the r rated hypnotists and
he had a, a killer fucking show.
He used to do it at stitches comedy club.
And when I first saw it,
I was 21 I was totally skeptical.
I was like,
there's no way this guy's gonna hit and
ties all these people 20 minutes into it,
you know? Absolutely. 100% that
these people are hypnotized.
And the crazy thing is
this kind of mumbles
transcendental as he's talking like this.
How's everybody doing? Lazy. Dominating.
Okay, I'm going to count to
three and I bought a three.
You're going to go to sleep. One, two,
three clicks are asleep. And like,
what the fuck?
I barely understood what this guy said,
but meanwhile he's running around
touching him. Oh, your boobies.
Boobies are so happy. You're gonna,
you're going to play with them right now.
You're gonna play with the babies and
chicks would just playing with their kids.
Yeah. They would say, you are right
now. You are my friend. You, uh,
you have a raging erection.
Whoa. You can't even believe.
You can't believe you're actually,
the guy looks down as erection.
He goes and who's
underneath you right now?
Mcdonogh is like 1980s when you know you
didn't jump away in disgust and horror.
You know those fucking veiny monster Dick
arms. She's got like Dick's for arms.
That's what they look like.
It was like someone's hard Dick Madonna,
Madonna's arms la,
like someone's the head
decks cause they're all veiny.
And fucking weird and sinewy and shit.
Flip like a raging Dick. She's raging Dick
arms. But anyway, he would do this bit,
you know, uh, Madonna's underneath
you and guys would not in their pants.
So give it to you, give it to you
and, and you're going to come, oh,
and the guy would like lay there like
this and you'd go get the fuck out.
You realize that I just noted in his
pants like, oh, a hundred percent dealer.
They, dude, Frank Santos is a master at
that. I know. He still does shows. Yeah,
on the East Coast around
Boston and Rhode Island.
I think he's originally from
Providence, Rhode Island. And he did,
he used to have shows.
He used to book shows too.
He was one of the first guys I actually
headlined for you headlined meanie and
there's little room that he did in, in
Rhode Island. Really? Really great guy.
But um, he was, uh, the
funniest hypnotist too,
cause he was always like really dirty,
ridiculous shit that he would make
these people do. But when it was over,
you know, hey wake them up
and snap him out of it. Man.
The look on their face like they
didn't have a fucking clue was to,
it was like Eddie Bravo after
a night of Jack Daniels.
It was just just fucking who where,
where am I? Who's closer are these,
I bet his sex life is awesome.
Eddie Bravo. The hypnotist.
Cause you just hypnotize a chick.
That's funny you just said that because
there was a guy who was a hypnotist
slash comedian at the comedy
store and he was really gross.
He was kind of a creepy dude who at one
point in time was like kind of funny
like back in the 80s but something
happened along the way and he never really
hit and it was always kind of stuck
around and went up to him like cruises and
weird shit.
But now,
so now he's like in his
50s and not successful and
creepy and really not funny.
You would go on stage and not be funny,
but he was always trying to
hypnotize bitches. That was his move.
And so one time I was at the comedy store,
like one of the last times I was there
and I went to the cover booth to ask
something and he was in the corner
with his check and all I heard was, no,
I'm not going to let you hypnotize me.
Well that's the thing like you have
like apparently trust is a huge,
you can't just go around
hypnotizing random people.
They got one if he was
trying just swinging. No,
he was asking let me touch
you. Let me, yeah, cause they
got, they got to accept it.
You know, I want her to drowning my dick.
Is that or read, you're in the lake.
There's only one way to breathe.
Talking about fighting it.
I need to take a read from
those missing in action movies.
I remember they would always hide from
the Vietcong by grabbing to read and they
would go under it,
breathed through the rebid pitch.
Try breathing through a fucking read when
your heart's beating 150 pizzas second
snorkels and Jesus Christ got damaged.
You can't breathe through a fucking read.
I tried breathing for a snorkel
shitty one that I bought at like some
convenience store. There's
terrible, yeah, it's claustrophobic.
If you added about another button and
a half to it will be nearly impossible
just because of the heaviness of the air.
Oh really? Yeah. That's what does it,
it's the compression of the air.
Even under a little bit of water like so
I guess 30 feet is an entire atmosphere,
I believe of pressure like a doubles
your whole atmosphere. So whatever,
varying degrees of that.
But that's what makes it so hard.
It's because you're sucking,
you know, heavier air through
that, through that, uh,
instead of apparatus. Yeah. Well it's
just hard breathing through. First of all,
hard through a too.
And for the longest time I used to have
to only breathe through my mouth because
my nose was busted up,
like got my nose fixed.
They opened it up and now I can breathe
through my nose and my mouth and I'm
like, oh, sweet oxygen come to me.
And so when I'm in the water with
that shitty scuba thing, I was like,
this is fucking gross. Just breeding
only out of your mouth again.
So knowing a bit claustrophobic.
Yeah,
you get a little claustrophobic and you
also realize like how you know how you
need your nose to fucking breathe with.
Like I have friends that
have not had that operation,
the deviated septum operation and they're
dudes who fucked up noses. I'm like,
Bro, get that shit fixed man. I'm telling
you. And some guys are like, well,
I'm just going to break it again anyway,
like fighters. And I'm like, so what?
Break getting in any way? Trust me,
I get it fixed. Get it fixed now.
Because you know,
you don't realize how much more you can
breathe out of your fucking nose when
your nose works.
You know you got like 30% more cardio
that way and you smell farts way better.
And I always knew when Brian was smoking
this motherfucker tell us he quit
smoking. I'm like, bitch, I smell
cigarettes. Damn you and your new nose.
I know fucks. Figgis was fun though.
We had a good goddamn time. That was a,
that was the best time
we ever had at those.
The best audience we ever had in Vegas
too, for sure. Right? Yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, definitely. It was great.
But what was even better as Ari and Jodie
is at the UFC, Joe. Yeah, that's right.
Ari and Joey dropped acid at the UFC and
they kept on like saying they're going
to dose me the whole weekend.
Like you're either going to take it or
I'm going to dose you and you're not
going to know about it.
So you choose which one impression that
I didn't want to yell it, but it wasn't
cock sucker. Well, now that we have these,
we have these puff shields because
people are complaining about our ps,
what do they call pop shield
pops shields or something.
Fucking professional folks.
This,
we've reached the next
evolution of this fucking thing.
I'd like to hide behind
him. But uh, Joey and Ari,
by the time we went to a
dinner right after the fights,
they were fucking blasted.
Just glassy eye.
And what's funny is I, when I've, a
couple of times ago, UFC is ago, uh,
there was this time when,
I think it was one of the first times
I ever went to the USC with Ari and Ari
was like dropping down on the ground.
He was being so emotional about the whole
thing. And he's like, oh, by the way,
I never told you this, but that
time I was on ecstasy and I'm like,
well that makes sense. So, Whoa,
whoa. What UFC did you take?
Excess is the one where,
uh, what's his name? Uh,
with a short guy with
the long hair? Uh, yeah,
his mom was sitting on one side on
the ground crying because his is,
there were fighting and an Ra was on
the other side on the ground going like
acting really weird and, and I
thought, yeah, go, I can't American
click, click, Click Guido. That, no,
it wasn't that fun cause that
if I wasn't the palms. No, no.
This was a in Vegas and I remember it was,
it wasn't Vegas, was it the big arena?
No, it's a small arena. Oh,
so it wasn't the palm. Yeah,
cause I can't imagine his mom crying. Oh,
so it must've been that one. Yeah. Yeah.
So his mom's freaking out in one site
in Ari's freaking out on the air side.
And I always thought like, wow, I
never went to USC with Aria. But man,
he's really into it.
USC and he's like a 1940s I keep
like he would sit there and be like,
yes. Like yes. Like I
was thinking like, wow,
you guys really go to
very many at the palms.
It might've been one of the only ones
who've ever went to that, right? No,
I've been to about five at the pond.
Have you really done? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh was it the hard rock?
I'm confusing. What? Yeah.
I've never been to the hard rock. Okay.
We used should do them at the hard rock.
You know the palms is the
best place to see that.
It's my favorite best place for the UFC.
Yeah,
there's not a bad seat in the
house. Yeah, it's awesome.
And even though like the first level,
it's like perfect height, you know,
that I fucking wish they were all
at the palms elevated sucks is that,
well it's awesome for the people that
are in the back, that little back area,
like behind these,
like most of the seats are facing one
side of the icon and then there's just
some bleachers on the
other side of the octagon,
which is like the dopest seats ever,
which is where they sit like rockstars
and shit. Yeah. You know, but it's like,
you know, there's, it's only like how many
thousands of seats for 40,000. Not much.
It's fucking incredible nights.
It's incredible. Super intimate too.
They do comedy shows. Their Katt Williams
does a comedy shows there. But um,
so he was on ecstasy at this
time, that time. And so that,
that explains it because I ever since
when Todd Duffy was in your way and you
wanted him to move and no one
could get them to me. Yeah.
That was [inaudible] right in front of
Brian seat screaming Kubu no up the foods
yet. He's one of those guys. I
just stood up the whole fight.
You don't stand up the whole fight.
If something crazy happens. Sure.
Everyone stands up together kind of thing,
even though that's annoying. But he,
he stood up the whole fight in front of
me and I'm not gonna say anything to the
guy,
but,
but that wasn't the fight that this was
one where we were sitting like in the
front row, almost like on,
on regular chairs. Okay.
So you guys got the sweet cvs sweet seats.
But uh, and so then I always thought,
ever since then I'm like, wow, I never
knew our, he loved the UFC that much.
That's really crazy. By the way, those
seeds in the floor and not as good, right?
No one above is the best. Yeah. One above
is the best. And even like this last one,
we actually had the second one,
like front row seats,
but the second tier and it
was perfect because you,
we just kind of like looked
over the whole ring, you know,
it's like nothing was in the way.
No camera man were in the
way when they hit the ground.
You could see the grounds. So it was
awesome. The floors like the pimp spot,
you know, you're like, I'm on the floor
a bitch, you know, but it's really not.
It's like it's a good show each side.
Like deep in the floor. Yeah. Right.
Front row floor is the only
good thing about the floors.
Looking at gender Jamison the whole time.
She's whoever she brings with
you doing this really fancy suit.
Anybody that does well on new UFC
though, it's a, it's a kick ass Yvette.
There's nothing like it.
I mean it's,
you think like you'd watch them on TV
but it's different when you're there like
it is. Hola. Si. Yeah.
He texted me in the middle of it in
middle of a while. He was on acid.
He goes,
how is this not like Roman
Colosseum texted me while
I was blasted on the asset.
Right. And I thought it was an interesting
text, you know? I mean, but it's,
we always think that, and we always
say this, I said right word, you know,
that's what I said back to them. But
then if I had known and he was on acid,
yeah I should have said,
well by the way, I'm on now.
But they didn't want me to tell.
They don't want me to tell you until,
I don't know why. But
they were like, okay,
you can tell Joe now and so I I what you
were worried about last time about the
air? Yeah, I, Joey Diaz and ours. You fear
run acid right now. Enjoy your replay.
But it was funny because the whole
time Ari's like tears in his eyes.
So emotional like when the graphics kind
of how it should be a little bit though
when the graphics came
on and he's just like,
oh this is so great and I
wouldn't take it because of,
to me I've done acid a thousand times,
but it's like,
to me acid is nature.
Acid is being with your friends.
Camping acid is sitting on your
couch watching pink Floyd the wall.
It's not in a coliseum with
thousands of crazy fucking gaps.
Mushrooms,
I like mushrooms could actually be better
than acid cause that's kind of more of
a trans mutable, neat
feeling. Like, I mean,
obviously the Vikings
would take mushrooms,
have a shirkers before
they would go into war.
Like you can really maneuver it around.
The vikings were really into the AMANITA
miscarried. That was their shows it.
So it's a weird mushroom man was there,
would get all hopped up on that.
And we're invincible. Yeah. That's
tricky. As mushroom to get right apparent.
I did it once and it was not
good. It didn't work. It's key.
Gave me a weird effect,
but then we mix it up with [inaudible],
cubensis mushrooms and it was a blast
off like somehow the two of them together
just while we're on APP. But the Amnesia
miscarry Mascara by itself, very tricky.
Apparently it varies.
Not just genetically, but
geographically and seasonally.
So it's like you gotta get the right
strain from the right part of the world.
Like I found something in my property
in Colorado when I was up there and a,
I was like,
I'm not going to take this.
I'll probably not even going to be
worth it. You know, I'd be twice.
You're gonna acquire them. Really? I
know what it is. It's pretty clear. Yeah,
there's no doubt when you see
an Amnio to miscarry, you know,
big red cap looks like Santa Claus.
It's Santa Clause.
Don't just go eating anyway.
Yeah, I like this. It's so tempting when
you see like a mushroom in your backyard.
Living was big poofy ones. Just wanted to
cook it. It does look delicious. Right?
Faster back there. Yeah. You better
know your shit son. Yeah. Mommy.
Julie brought a cow shit.
And there's some that look very close
to psychedelic mushrooms that give you
just irreversible liver damage to
some of them they just fuck you.
Mushrooms are so weird man.
Like some of them are super nutritious
and other ones will just fucking crush
you.
Don't do all kinds of stuff.
Like the Reishi mushroom gives you a lot
of good energy and and stuff from it.
It's not psychedelic this nutritional
health wise, I'll Chaga, Chaga, mushroom,
mushrooms, really good. I
started taking out recently.
Imagine like if I was at the, the,
the greatest moment for me was the uh,
the rampage chuck
l buildup.
Fight wasn't obviously that good,
but that moment in that
ring was fucking unreal.
It's just the energy that was built up.
Just people had someone that
wanted to win for that flight.
What's the biggest fight you've ever
seen was that that was probably the,
that was probably the biggest I would
say. I mean for me, I mean, I seen,
I've seen some, um, yeah,
I'd have to say that was it.
People care about that one. I think
you're going to have to come. Well,
you're going to have to come for
Brock Lesnar Junior. Dos Santos. Yeah.
That's going to be chaos. I saw Brock
beat 'em at UFC 100 who was that?
It was at mirror than, yeah, those mirror
saw that. Saw that one. That was big.
That was a good event thing. So magical
as the, there's a few big ones coming up,
man. You've got to go to that one
though. Brock and junior. Dos Santos,
I don't know when it's scheduled
for. It's GSP next. He's in Toronto.
He's going to be fighting in
April against Jake shields.
That's a good fucking fight. He wins
that. He gets Anderson, right? Yeah.
Good luck with a prize.
I would go with,
I would fucking slip on a banana peel
all the way to the locker room. Yeah,
I would go to that text.
The amazing thing is like I do,
I kick front kicks,
you know,
and I have a little target little tag
on my bag and I can sometimes kick the K
or whatever like that and in the letters,
but the way his accuracy in a fight where
people are moving and he wrapped all
five toes around v Tours.
Chimp just perfectly,
didn't even sprain a toe during a Friday.
Never seen anybody get knocked out
with a front lever for after that,
a couple of people sent me some videos
like there's one from k, one max,
some my Japanese got landed a Badass
front kick right to the draw. Same thing.
Knocked the dude out.
Cold Guy fell back like he got shot.
His was actually better than the v.
Tore one cause or wasn't totally
out right door was moving still.
This guy just Bam just fell back like he
got shot at front kick right to the job.
It's just so hard to land on people.
The guy in k one max,
so he threw a gang of
them to the body first.
He threw a bunch of them to the body
over and over again and then just shocked
one up to the face and caught the dude
perfectly on the jaw and knocked him
unconscious. Yeah. Yeah. I'd never seen
any in all the MMA fights that are called,
I've called over a thousand fights.
I've never seen a front kick
to the jaw knockout. Yeah.
Usually when someone front
kick someone in the face,
they just knock their head back.
Yeah. It's kind of a, yeah,
it's like flashing the flight of
their foot. He said some whip in that,
in that too. That was a
front snap. Can't snap.
That was karate style push kicks or
just kind of move somewhere back.
But he whipped it up. Yeah. As nasty.
Well that's because everybody does like
the Thai style, you know, which is like a,
it's a team, you know, it's like you're
pushing the guy off you and they're,
they're really trying to
regulate with roundhouse kicks.
They're trying to like get there and
you'd get their distance and push the guy
off you.
Yeah,
but like some guys will throw the front
ball kick the snappy like semi Schilt
Semi Shelf Fox people up with that thing
dropped Pete Williams in the UFC with
it. He stopped, bought her Hari with and
he, that's how he won the Grand Prix.
He hit, bought her heart with a front kick
to the liver. He just, he's a giant too.
I mean some shelters, legitimately a
giant. He's seven feet tall, you know.
So he curls
those toes back and sends that
fucking gigantic log your way.
That log he calls a foot. Yeah. Yeah man.
There's nothing quite like watching
fights. It's just, there's nothing more,
nothing that really caters to the
chimpanzee instinct more, you know,
a great game. No matter how much you
enjoy it is still just a game. You know,
the thrillers are just not as high.
You know,
it doesn't matter if it's hockey or
baseball or oh my goodness, the ball.
You went over the park. Exactly. Yay. Many
have a whole, you know, blog about that.
I mean it's really sport boiled
down to its very roots. I mean it,
we have those aspects and other sports,
like you see Dwayne Wade dunk on somebody
and it's fully like he dunks on him
and he's in his face and it's like
he dominates. It's likely not to.
But then there's Elton pedals does that
showtime kick when he kicks off the
caging but kicks Ben Henderson
the face of the same foot.
It'll just an approximation
of what we're really after,
which is primal conflict in dominance.
You know,
you have all these balls and all
these rules and all these things,
but it's still just men exercising
that primal instinct to dominate.
But what I've always said is
that if you fucking route of it,
if you know someone, if you slam dunk a
ball and someone, they can always say,
well yeah, well I can kick your ass, but
no one gets their ass kicked and goes,
yeah, well I can slam dunk a
ball on you. Nobody gives a fuck.
It doesn't go the other way.
That's interesting, isn't it?
Fucking just fucking human nature. And I
think why people are so attracted to it.
Fastest growing sport in the world.
I don't know if that's still an accurate
quote, but it was going around for sure.
It's there's not even a close
second. Yeah. Talking about the fee,
it's only been around in this country in
this form since the 90s [inaudible] 93
was the first one that had no rules and
then as far as like sanctioning is just
a few years after that we started getting
sanctioned and athletic commissions,
but yeah,
there's not even a close second.
It makes perfect sense because
people miss that aspect of life.
I mean everything is so watered down now.
You don't get to exercise that,
that kind of physical component of
our psyche that still those DNA,
those genes haven't changed in the last
hundred 200 years where we're not doing
that anymore or go about
time. Thousand. Yeah,
10,000 we have the same genetic makeup
as people 10,000 years ago. Supposedly.
That's obviously that's
incredibly theoretical until
we go back in time and take
a guy from 10,000 years ago and
examine him. But from all accounts,
if you took a guy from even a hundred
thousand years ago and put them in natural
close,
you know,
or rather a normal clothes that we would
wear and put them in a movie theater,
that guy would just sit there. You
wouldn't even be able to still show. Yup.
So the movie start playing and then
he starts shit, it's fucking pants
here and shit over himself to make it
less attractive to the monster in the
screen. Curling in the
corner. Knock knock.
Yeah. Yeah. But you know
those, that DNA is still in,
of course it's still the same hardware.
It's basically what it used to
get a chance to exercise that.
Like they would go to war.
Like I was just, you know,
I was just talking to you
about Socrates is a warrior.
You think of this philosopher, you think
about us. He was a bad ass. Just a killer.
You know, he was one of the
hoplites for the Athenian army.
And where did you read
about all this with socks?
So I learned about it
from Steven Pressfield's
book, tides of war, and then I
did a ton of research and, and uh,
and put it all on my block
but just up a bad ass.
Like some of the stories are crazy.
Like he was a,
there was a retreat
coming from, um, from, uh,
from place to go on a call d Liam.
And in this retreat basically the
Athenians pushed forward and the flank,
their flank got, um, got weak on the left
and right side. And then the other, uh,
general [inaudible],
the other general,
they are fighting against [inaudible]
and general who also invented the flame
thrower, which is pretty
sweet. But anyways,
so you outflanked them and
then the Athenians, you know,
everybody started throwing
those around back then.
I know he invented the flame
thrower later, but anyways, so, so,
so on the retreat they have like a
three hour run back to back to Delia.
And Socrates just stayed
like right at the point,
like the very back of his men and just
fought for three hours like horses coming
out of just cutting them down,
keeping people from running
up the backs and slashing it.
Its own a Athenian soldiers. I mean it
was still a blood bath, but he was like,
do we really know what happened?
That could have been some gay dude.
The Socrates fucked real good.
Willing to tell crazy stories because
Socrates was a big queen, right?
They're all gay. Back then they were full
of Shit, man, I don't buy that story.
You look at like Socrates
might've been run like a girl.
I believe.
I have to write poetry.
Look at his mug though. Looking
back, the actual bust of it,
the dude looks like a fuck,
but we don't know.
We don't know what he really looks like.
We know drawings while they say they
sculpted them, those motherfuckers
accurate lion who runs the worst place
on the back. Then they were honest.
That's what's hilarious.
You know, we assume,
I mean people are completely
full of shit today.
Why would we assume that they'd be honest?
All this fucking Ronald Reagan
revisionist history is driving me crazy.
As an adult who was an adult
during the Reagan administration,
Reagan had something like 200 people or
more that were in his cabinet and his in
the doe that were employed by him in the
White House connected to him that wound
up getting arrested,
get guilt getting brought up on charges.
There's some ridiculous number. I mean,
George Carlin had a routine on it.
He had a whole routine on it about find
it, find George Carlin Reagan's gang,
because it's just like when you really
like go back and listen to it, you look,
oh yeah, that's right. Yeah.
They were all fucking crooks.
They're all crooks and figured out how
to manipulate the moral majority and to
go with the religious right and get,
you know,
religious people in Christian finally
organize to vote for the presidency.
That shit didn't exist before with
Nixon and with Carter and with Ford.
There was,
there wasn't that,
there wasn't like a big political
movement with Christians.
That became a reality during
the Reagan administration.
The Reagan administration was sponsorable
was responsible for so much fucked up
shit. So much fucked up
shit man. That people don't,
I mean even stuff that people don't,
um, that don't agree with today,
like in the conservative
movement that support Reagan,
like negotiating with terrorists
and all kinds of other shit.
Like there's a dude who called into
the rush Limbaugh show and it's, uh,
somebody put up in the article
about it on my website and um,
it was a,
a really fucking funny
conversation because this guy
was like really well versed
in the history of Ronald Reagan. I said,
this guy starts arguing with, um, with uh,
with rush Limbaugh telling him about
what, what Reagan did, um, that uh,
Reagan raised taxes on social security
that Regan negotiated with terrorists
sending over and over again arms to Iran
in exchange for hostages performed by
contrast, Jimmy Carter didn't
give an inch to the Iranian, so,
which is why we can never get their rent.
The hostages is soon as
Reagan got into office,
the literally like right away the
terrorist from I ran were released.
Why is that? Why is that?
Because they gave him something,
they had to give them something to,
to negotiate with terrorist
to get these people back.
Is it worth it to get the people back?
Yeah,
but I guarantee you part of the agreement
was don't let them back until we're an
office. It's not really about them being
free. It's about it looking good for us.
Right. Guaran fucking tee. You yell.
We just live Ollie north cause you
get the thing about Reagan. So listen,
it's 12 minutes long.
We're not going to listen to all of it,
but just play it a little bit because
George Carlin fucking nailed it.
And this is back in, you
know, I think he did this. Uh,
she was probably like the nineties,
early, early nineties. Yeah.
Like right after Reagan had.
Yeah.
Ben,
I really haven't seen this many people
in one place since they took the group
photographs of all the criminals in
law breakers in the Ronald Reagan
administration.
Yeah.
George Carlin was the shit.
225 of them to 25 people in the Ronald
Reagan administration have either quit or
been fired,
been arrested,
indicted or convicted of either breaking
the law or violating the ethics code.
225 of them.
What do you think the total number of
the Niso laws and how many that haven't
gotten bone has been investigated by
three separate special prosecutors and
there's a fourth one waiting
for him in Washington right now.
Three separate special prosecutors have
had to look into the activities of the
attorney general and the attorney
general is the nation's leading law
enforcement officer. He can kill it
right there. See, that's what you got.
That's crazy. What the fuck man?
What the fuck? And everybody's like.
Ronald Reagan was an amazing man.
It's like we have this image of him just
like our grandpa that you know was a
drunk and he used to beat the fuck out
of your grandma and you just kind of
forget it. When I get older, it's
like grandpa was, was a good guy.
I remember thinking I loved Ronald Reagan
growing up just because of the 80s,
kind of embraced Ronald Reagan and
there was like artwork in, you know,
just like shows. What about Ronald
Reagan? And then we're like, wow,
Ronald Reagan likes jelly beans.
That's so cool. You know? And yeah,
Jimmy Carter had peanuts with me
in there, but it's like, well,
doesn't that show that Ronald Reagan's
unhealthy and bad for America? Yeah, man.
I don't know.
It's the whole thing is very interesting.
It's very interesting how we like
to look back in the past with rosy,
rosy vision,
know if you want to get really
big sometime and go to the Ronald
Reagan museum down there. I did that,
I did that the other, uh,
like a couple of years ago.
It's over here like in Calabasas
somewhere. Yeah, it's fucking huge.
And the whole thing is
just Ronald and Nancy.
Like you'd go on these little movie
theaters and just plays like videos with
them in it.
You have air force one there.
You can go and see like
where Ronald Reagan,
they'd like his plane and like on
this desk there's like jelly beans.
It's so gay. But it's crazy.
It's too much. Reagan though,
after a while you're just like, all
right, I've had too much Reagan.
I can't take this anymore.
The only thing that I really liked about
Reagan when he was in office was when
he started talking about aliens.
One of the things he talked
about with the Russia,
like how much we would all forget our
differences if we had been attacked by
aliens from another planet. And I was
like, Oh shit. What does he know? Yeah.
And everybody,
and he didn't do it in just one speech.
He did it in a couple of speeches.
That same sort of a little hints. Well,
I want to know,
is it little hints or is he just fucking,
is it just someone wrote something cool.
I mean,
it's not like Reagan wrote that Shit.
That's just know more than, you know.
Some Charlie Sheen writes his dialogue
for two and a half men. I mean,
it's basically the same job. You know,
Reagan didn't write all that stuff.
Somebody else wrote that. Maybe there's
just some cool ass fucking speechwriter.
It's like, let's just freak these mother
fuckers out. Some alien talk. You know,
everybody's a little
freaked out about Russia.
How are we going to bring him down?
I don't know, man. I don't, again,
we're worried about the bomb.
I'm like, look, you know
the mom's not going to land.
I know the bumps on the land,
but we can't tell about how we're really
in cahoots with Russia to keep the
world down. So what do you want to
do? How about we bring on Barrington?
How about we just start freaking people
to fuck out talking about aliens from
another planet and how much we would
come together. I like it. I like it.
Did you see the video of the Ufo over
Jerusalem? It didn't. Is a fake. Yeah.
Who made it sounded making
that you're talking about one.
There's two camera angles.
I didn't, I only saw one.
The weird ones like just sits there
and then they go straight up. Yeah,
it's completely fake with crazy.
As I showed up to Alison and rocks that
was on the podcast and immediately she
saw it. She goes, that's fake.
That's actually a tool in whatever it
was like Adobe premier or something like
that. That's hilarious. Like three d
or something like that. She's like,
I could show you how to do them
or when people fake this shit.
Cause then everybody thinks every
fucking videos back and there is a lot of
fakes that,
don't get me wrong,
but there's somebody who's that are legit
footage of shit that happened because
there's thousands of people
who saw it on the ground,
like of that Mexico City shit
that's not fake. I just showed you
Joe a video the other day that I wanted
to see what he thought about it because
I thought it was fake. It's about this
hamster that was just fighting and,
and no Joe Joe's. Joe Still doesn't
think it's fake. I still think it's fake.
And then I was talking to Ari about him.
It's like,
why do I think that video is fake?
And then I realized,
did you notice the stomach of it was
pitch black? Like I was just like,
like all black of the stomach to know,
listen to me, you're thinking too much.
And I know,
but I'm thinking like real people don't
know what the fuck you're talking about.
There's a video online. What
is it called? Angry hamster,
hamster fighting or angry Hampshire.
What? Anyway, the video is,
these guys are fucking with
this hamster on the hamster,
gets crazy on them and tried to bite them.
And then eventually like Eddie
Murphy movie. No, no, no, no.
That's a professor I think.
Anyway, it's a fucking scared little
animal that's biting people. I mean,
it's real. It's 100% real hamster of
do forget about the pod. Um, so, um,
so tell me what are your thoughts on,
on Ufo?
So what shift do you think that you
saw that you think that was like, well,
digital
question. I mean, I think some of those,
I think in every major country, you know,
it's particularly, I think actually back
even farther, you know, into history,
there's been paintings of
Ufos and different things,
people all the way back to caves and
other different biblical sightings of, um,
of things appearing over battlefields
and crazy shit like that.
And you can take all that history
with some footage that we have now.
Some reports from just super sober pilots,
just dudes that are like, look, I don't,
I don't really, really like that.
I saw this, I fucking hate it.
I'm not trying to get anything out
of this, but this is what happened.
We chase this thing. It was doing
crazy stuff. No way we could catch it,
are machines shut off and we had to
return to base. Like I saw it, you know,
whatever. And they're not trying to gain
anything out of it. And those, those,
I think those are really credible.
Whereas a lot of these other people who
are trying to our, I am the Ufo seer,
you know, like talk to me about, those are
fucking quacks. But so many just sober,
gritty people just talking about it.
Yeah. The very first, uh, explanation
or the very first depiction,
the flying saucer depiction was
from a pilot was from a, you know,
a military pilot who was watching
these things skip across the sky.
And I forget the dude's name, but, um,
I should probably give him credit for
it because it's kind of an interesting
thing to come up with. And he
said it seemed like saucers
skipping across a lake.
Yeah. Yeah. Um,
I'm not opposed to the idea of there
being some visitors from somewhere else,
whether it's from here that we can't
see, you know, some, a dimension nearby,
whether it's from another planet.
I'm not opposed to that.
But what I am opposed to is all these
people that have the explanation for it
like so quickly and all these people that
are like looking for proof of aliens,
they're like,
they're getting crazy and like,
like you ever watch that ancient
alien show? No, I haven't,
but I know what you're talking
about. Yeah. You gotta watch it.
It's the most ridiculous shit ever.
Like 80% of the stuff they say,
you're just like, what the fuck
are you talking about? Like, like,
why are you coming to this conclusion?
It's like the most unscientific
conclusion ever. Just read. Like they,
they'll like,
they'll find some ancient stone structures
that are like these giant stones like
in Peru,
whether it's really amazing how perfectly
these stones are fitted to the stones
below them in their hundreds of tons,
I mean enormous structures
and they go this,
there's only one way
this could have happened.
It had to have been helped from another
planet. And the people, uh, just,
it makes me think, I wonder if they
had help from another planet and okay.
Or maybe people had been around a
lot fucking longer than you think.
And we know for sure there's been some
massive cataclysmic close mic disasters
just during recorded history. We know,
we know there's been some big ones in,
you know, the, the near distant past,
some mass extinctions that that killed
the dinosaurs that fucking, you know,
changed a bunch of that shit in the
climate many, many, many times over.
Wouldn't you just assume that people,
but around,
isn't that like the number one thing you
would go to? We know people are real.
All right. We know people
invent some crazy shit. We
know disasters happen. Yeah.
Maybe people figured out how to make
some crazy shit and the disaster happened
and then they forgot how to
make that crazy shit. Well,
a few stragglers made it out,
taught a few things. I mean these,
these things that they have in Peru
though, the man is fucking fascinating.
Just really enormous fucking stones. And
they had a discovery recently in Turkey.
Let me find this real
quick because it's a,
it predates archeological. A construction,
like they're like, or rather,
um, the, uh, the oldest
construction, the oldest,
like real modern stone carving blood
by like fucking some insane number,
like five or 6,000 years.
So like what they thought was
like the beginnings of dawn's,
of civilization back in Mesopotamia
and a 6,000 years ago, yeah.
This predates that by another 6,000,
right. Massive fucking stone structure.
Tons and tons of stone moved. Like,
what the fuck is this? Yeah. You know?
Yeah. And then, you know, the stories
of a, of the Atlantean culture.
Obviously there's a lot of bs surrounding
that, but it's like, what does it mean?
Yeah.
There's a pretty good chance that there
was an advanced civilization that got
wiped out, you know, by either
earthquake or media or something.
Just took them out. Yeah, for
sure. Man. 11,000, 500 years ago,
this thing was built
7,000 years before the,
what they think was the great pyramid
more than 6,000 years before Stonehenge.
And they built this gigantic
fucking thing in Turkey.
And there was another store recently
about this guy from Australia who started,
uh, looking all throughout Saudi Arabia
with Google maps or Google earth.
And you know,
Google Earth will bring a
voc and literally zoom you
in on the surface of the
entire Middle East.
And this mother fucker found like 1700
archeological discoveries and sites like,
there's all this ancient shit while
these guys are blowing themselves up.
I thought,
I thought it was just the,
the whole gang of people found that that's
the total number of [inaudible]. Oh,
really? Yeah. That's
not one to one person.
And now I know it's just that it's a
total number of posts since Google maps.
Okay, well I'm, I might have misread it,
but the one guy who did do it
had a friend in Saudi Arabia.
He was in Australia where the
store is based on heading to us.
He's a Australian guy,
but he had a friend in Saudi Arabia.
So he would give the guy the coordinates
and then the guy would go there and
take photos of the actual area and
then they would send it to you know,
experts and they'd be like, yeah, that's
some fucking shit. Right. That's crazy.
And civilization have any one of these
assholes are throwing rocks at each other
and fucking screaming about
none my rules. Right. You know,
they're,
they're fighting over nonsense over
there when they're in the middle of this
incredible archeological.
Yeah.
When treasure trove people 12,000 years
ago would pimp slap you for being an
idiot and they're in the same
place. That's pretty, uh,
pretty telling there that you're not
going the right way, not the right way.
You need to change directions.
You know what's going to happen with
Egypt now with Egypt? Uh, I have,
I heard the museum's got looted.
Yeah. Kairos just fucking chaos man.
I mean they have to say ratable
archaeological discoveries
that they have stored
there. I mean, who knows what's still
there, what they'd been able to protect.
But apparently it's so bad that you know,
no one can even get an audit of what's
happened and what hasn't happened.
We're watching a dictatorship
fall before our eyes.
And here's the thing to consider and
this is the thing that no one's going to
tell you when you're watching
all this go down. And you know,
the United States is like, you
know, we, we need, you know,
Mubarak should step down immediately and
who's behind this?
Did you guys do this?
Like, I see the, you know,
like I see Obama on TV talking
about it and I see, and I'm like,
who when I was younger I
would say, well, here's this,
here's a group of people that are
raising up against their, their,
their tyrant leader, right? I mean,
this guy is obviously a dictator
and he needs to be removed.
But he's been our ally in that area
for a long ass time. Yeah. Okay.
Why is it that all of a sudden
people are rising against him?
Why is it w who's organizing all this?
Is the CIA?
Wasn't there a recent election
or something? Wasn't there like,
I mean that's pretty much it.
In the past it's,
it's hard to get people to move like
this. It's hard to get people to, uh,
to really rise up. I mean, for sure
they are pissed off for sure. They are,
they have had enough of this
fucking Douche bag, you know,
wanting to run things in
their fucking crazy country.
But what real people are really afraid
of is that the Sharia law, you know,
that 64% of Egyptians want
to be governed by Sharia law.
They want to be governed by Islamic law.
So it's like, man, having this guy out,
it's not good.
And it's like,
it is good for the Egyptian people
because they get their own choice. But,
but dejection people,
even though some of them are progressive
and many of them like Iran and I ran up
a big percentage of the people don't
want anything to do with the way I ran as
being perceived by the Western world.
And they don't want have anything to
do with religious fundamentalism or the
craziness that has always been associated
with. I ran their young people,
they listen to fucking music and they
like art and they want to get the fuck out
of this. There's terrible situation,
but they're stuck. You know?
And I think there's a lot of those
types of people in Egypt too,
but it's just like America man. Even if
there's 50% of the people that you know,
believe that, you know, we need
science and stem cell research is good.
There's another 50% to believe they saw
fucking the devil in their cheerios and
they want to fucking shoot it with
a gun. You know? I mean we've got,
we've got a real problem like that.
I think the only way I've, you know,
been asked this question before and I
think the best solution I have is just you
got to set up like Mo drop
Internet over to uh, you know,
like if people get knowledge and
like see outside of their box,
that's the only thing that's
going to change their mind. Right.
You know like put in like
paid for broadband stations
and I closed off area so
people can go in there,
login and check some shit out.
Well it's interesting like you said that
because that was the first thing that
they did in Egypt when they
wanted to stop the resistance,
they shut off the Internet. That's what
Egypt did. They shut off the Internet.
Is this still off by the way?
I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know how much of it was off.
I don't know if they were able to
jury rig it and get it back on.
I don't even know what it is to be honest
to start talking to me about the Gumbo.
I don't even understand what the tubes
and pipes and how do you shut it off.
Is there a main switch somewhere? Did you
blow some shit up? Did you cut the cord?
Did we run a core through the bottom
of the ocean? All the way to America?
How the fuck does it get over here?
How does it get over here?
Is Your cord that goes from underneath
Europe under the owner? Is that real?
I think there is. That's ridiculous.
How Retro? Yeah, I think there is.
I think there's, okay. Well how the
fuck did they connect with each other?
Telephone lines. How do they connect
with each other? We don't know.
I'm pretty sure I would get bounced by
satellites but not in seventies there's
no satellites, but I don't think there's
salary. There's no, there was no internet.
No,
I'm saying,
but the Internet goes through telephone
lines and like that kind of wiring.
So you used to be able to call England
from the 70s how the fuck could you do
that? Back in the 70s you could call
any shirt. The ocean. So fucking deep.
So what did I do? Put It on loaders.
Yeah. What is due for ships?
Run into it and cut the cord.
And you gotta do it.
Just whales just hit it and you're like,
Hey,
I might be talking about on my ass
and maybe I'm just thinking about that
episode of loss might be targeted at your
ass, but you might not be, but I mean,
how the fuck could we call England?
Well, you know what, let's,
let's get as cowboys. Let's get a direct
answer from Twitter. You know I'm gonna,
I'm going to ask the folks on Twitter,
please tell me like,
how the fuck are you able to make phone
calls to Europe back in the 70s how the
fuck was there?
A cord that went all the way through
the goddamn ocean all the way to Germany
and shit.
Like I remember seeing a documentary,
how they did it or something like that.
And I could be just [inaudible]
please Twitter answer, answer me.
I saw Twitter's like educate
ball irreversible. By the way,
that the same guy that did it avoid Bingo.
Charge five photo says there is a
large fiber optic line in the ocean.
Okay. Here's the question
though. What the fuck man? What?
What happened back when there
was no fiber optics, right?
What did they do back in the 70s what
do they do in the 50s how did they let,
I mean, they usually show deep,
like it can't be on the bottom.
Where does that much fun?
I know what it's probably there's like
chasms in a business that runs through
there where you think there's a line
in like dudes are on like fucking
submarines and they see it common like,
shit,
we gotta we're gonna hit the phone
line or your line to get your tickets.
You killed the phones in New York.
Man. This guy says there's cables,
there's a transatlantic cable.
Wow. There was even back then.
There's a transatlantic
cable and the dude tow bang.
Just sent me a Wiki link.
Fuck yeah man. Holy Shit.
There is a God damn cable that's laid
across the floor of the Atlantic Ocean.
It crossed a telegraphic field.
Whoa. That's pretty dope.
So this is fascinating shit man. So what
the fuck is it with cell phones then?
Is that is a piggy piggyback on
those lines. International lines.
I'm putting in my satellites for cell
phones. How does that work? Yeah,
I think cell phones uses satellites now.
It does. Yeah. So if you connect from,
from one Australia to the United States,
I'm pretty sure it uses satellites.
Does that make sense? So, yeah, that's
what my guys, I said that last time I was,
let's say you Twitter. What? Say
you Twitter, please answer us.
It's like magic eight ball,
Bro. This is the most of me.
There's never been a time in life where
you could ask people questions like
this. And it's not even on radio
shows. You can pick a callers. No,
you get the text answers. Shit. This
guy is saying they sent letters by boat.
It's a girl. That's a stupid
answer. Shut your mouth.
You didn't think that shit through it all.
They sent letters by boat.
We're not talking about the 15
hundreds hooker on boat. Okay. Monkey.
Todd says it was a wire.
It was copper wire originally.
But what about what they're
doing right now? I mean,
how the fuck is it work right now
when you're sending, um, you know,
when you're sending a cell phone message
or calling someone, how's that work?
As of 2004, there's been
underwater cables, Huh? Yeah.
Cell phones use radio
signals. Yes. On Earth.
But radio doesn't go across the ocean.
You can't,
you don't even know what
the fuck was Cheyenne.
Goddammit taps into the same lines that,
yeah,
I would imagine it has to
use satellites nowadays.
Why there's a delay in the satellites.
It's gotta go way the fuck up to the
sky now. Because then if that was true,
there'd be no of like gaming, you know,
sells phones, use regular phone lines.
Apparently this guy saying
piggy backs somehow on regular
phone lines. Pinterest, you know,
it's kind of fucked up. It's just
like we were talking about with, um,
when your website gets a lot of
hits and it correct. By the way,
warrior poet is crushed son.
That shit ain't coming back.
If I could serve it just took a deep six.
I only have your business websites
crushed, but it's the same way with um,
with cell phone signals.
If there's an earthquake or some shit,
everybody tries to use their
phone. Good luck. Good luck.
You won't be able to use it
because everybody can't use
the phone at one stadium.
Yeah. It's like you're
there, they're under stocked,
like they're selling you cell
phone service and they're
selling it to everybody.
But the only way it works is that
everybody hasn't used it at the same time.
Yeah. Cause if everybody uses it at
the same time, nobody gets to use it.
It just shits out and just fucking
farts and dies. That's annoying.
That's annoying. It's like we, we're
um, we're too far ahead of ourselves.
You know, when it comes to technology,
we're too far out there. We're,
we're fucking try to stick this graph
on your message board of all the
underwater cables. Have you seen, did
you see that? Whoa, that's dope. A lot.
And that's a,
that's only my goddamn message boards.
[inaudible] we have to fix that shit.
It was getting crushed so much.
It's still private after I had to make
it where you only a member can you look
at it.
So you have to sign up for it to look
that up here that says there's been 150
years of Trans Trans Land at cable.
Wow.
150 150 years. That's insane.
Well, how the fuck did they do?
And if they go up higher through like uh,
they're floating on algae,
northern part of Canada and over through,
or if they're just straight through,
it comes right out of New York.
That's incredible.
That's 150 years of monster cables to how
long did it take to make those fucking
cables? Jesus Christ.
How long is it to get to,
if you take a boat from New York to
England, how long is that? How many miles?
Thousands of miles. Like
1500 miles. One cable.
That's thousands of miles long.
What the fuck do you carry that
hang on? 1500 no. Yeah, it's
like three. Yeah, take six hours.
Planes Go, what? 500
miles an hour. You know,
so what the fuck do you carry that with?
What do you carry that cable with?
You know, just had to be boats, getting
supplies and metal and then just try.
I just don't understand how they avoided
the chasms in the water. Like, Oh shit.
Like here's,
you know,
when you're fishing in the thing just
keeps going down and had a deep part of
lake or the parts of the ocean
are like 10,000 feet, you know,
a [inaudible] type stuff and wondering
why haven't terrorists try to attack that
cable?
Oh Shit. Fuck. [inaudible] brainstorming.
These dumb cunts are living in fucking
rock houses in the middle of the
mountains, banging goats and shit. Do
you think they can think this through?
We're didn't go do ocean and caught the
k but it are gone to kill farm there.
We gotta we gotta get, we gotta
get them online. That's the bottom.
We've got to get everybody. Well, you
know what you gotta do. Here's that deal.
Not just get them online. They have
to be around cool people. Dermabond,
douchebags.
Everyone around them is a douchebag.
It mean especially like in the Middle
East, the Middle East is just chaos,
Middle East or the townies of the world.
That's the cradle of civilization.
That's where it all started. And that's
why they're so behind the times. I mean,
the, the reason they're behind the
times and the reason why the America,
America is supposedly the most
progressive of the most advanced,
at least culturally of all the other
countries. The reason is because we're,
the last one were the one where everybody
fled to. And the first one, which is,
you know, the Middle East Mesopotamia
where Iraq is, that's the worst.
That's where it's the most fucked up.
That's the Sharia law.
That's Muslims versus Muslims.
That's, you know, chaos.
That's all those fucking dudes wearing
robes, circling around, you know, the,
the hodge at the mosque in Saudi
Arabia or whatever it is, the a mecca.
I mean,
that's all the same shit.
That's all that stuff that's been
around too long. You know. You know,
I was saying when we watched that,
um,
there was a TV show when I was
in Germany and a 24 hour, um,
Mecca station.
And it just 24 hours.
That's all it shows is people
circling the the box in Mecca,
circling that big square building. It's
crazy. It's fucking, but I was like,
if that she had happened today,
okay, if this is a new cult,
if some new Scientology type thing and
everybody's wearing robes and their
circle in that box, we'd be like, Whoa,
we got to stop these motherfuckers.
That is scary. If that, could you
imagine if that was in America? It looks,
say if that was in Kansas and there was,
you saw Bryant Gumbel disturbance
footage today out of Kansas.
We're going to go live here. Now,
granted, Ladies and gentlemen,
let's be aware of this. This dangerous
cult has only been around for five years,
but look how much they've organized in
these five years and then they showed
people Cirque around those boxes.
Dude,
there'd be helicopters flying towards
that to where we are right now.
Tanks would be moving down the highway.
Check
this out.
What if we,
what if we created a call that would
drink the blood of their hero every,
every, every week, figuratively,
if it was Megan Fox as well.
But that's what's happening.
Like you go to Catholic mass,
it's like here's the blood, here's the
flesh, drink the blood, eat the flesh.
I mean that's the look at that. That's
pagan. That is big and stuff right there.
But all but it because it's, Oh,
it's Christianity, it's Catholic.
Like we have a weird thing where
we just get used to shit. Yeah.
No matter how wacky it is,
you know, it's like these,
these broads in Africa with these
plates in their lips, you know,
Africa is another place where they
need some information. Like the,
especially in the mass side cultures and
stuff where they're getting their clits
cutoff with sharp stones.
The clutter ectomy out there like
they needed to do too, by the way.
They do a lot of that need
to see like Hannah Montana,
I'm like totally all need
Twitter addresses me bouncing
around singing whatever.
Isama been loud. It needs to check
in at four square at the Applebee's.
So we can fuck them up.
You know when they all need that shit.
Well, they already fucked him up, man.
Do you ever think that guy's alive?
I have no idea if he's even real.
It's probably in a fucking
London hotel somewhere.
A gang of boys sucking his dick.
They probably just said, listen,
we're not going to kill you, which
is, we're going to keep you alive.
You can make them every couple of years.
I need you in video.
Need you to come out with a new scary shit
so we can segway more civil liberties.
Do you think the last time that
there was real evil in a, in a,
in a war that we fought World
War II? Do you? Yeah, no,
I think there's real evil in Islamic
fundamentalism and Islamic terrorism.
I think there's definitely real evil.
I think the problem is unfortunately a
lot of that real evil has been caused by
our manipulation. Right?
Our being in, you know,
in religious holy grounds, you
know, and desecrated those grounds,
our involvement with and support
of dictators in the Islamic world.
And you know, some people say
like, guys like Hosni Mubarak,
like we need that guy around
to keep deal is, you know,
the Islamic fundamentalists
from gaining power.
Like at least he's like more moderate.
And even though it's he's a dictator,
it's the better of two evils.
And yeah, I don't know man.
I'm not well versed enough to
be realistically, you know, to,
to be honest about it. You know? I
mean if you really step back and said,
do you really understand how things
work in the Middle East? No. Fuck No.
I know that's another world.
It's another world man.
Maybe I remember him going to Abu Dhabi
and it becomes very aware, you know,
when we did a UFC and I would, I'd be
like, Yo, this is another world, you know,
don't get stupid, don't get
mouthy at the airport. You know,
they'll put you in a box on,
you know,
you'd better be polite and you better
realize that your laws or you know,
these laws rather very
different than yours. So out
of balance, I think, you know,
part of it is these patriarchal,
paternalistic religions. You know,
they just shift everything
way out of balance. You know,
like there used to be that balance of
the sacred feminine and the masculine,
but these desert religions are just
just shit on the feminine, you know?
And it's all about men,
you know,
control the women buying
the women hide the women.
Do you think that's because they
don't have much friends like water and
resources and natural?
Yeah.
I mean then all of a sudden they've got
this new resource over the last couple
of hundred years oil, you know,
that's really kind of a man. I mean,
how long has it even been,
has it even been a couple of hundred
years that we've been getting oil from the
Middle East, but whatever it's been, I
mean you look at photos of a Dubai 1970s
posted today. Back then there
was like nothing going on there.
Now it's fucking amends.
Sure. Well, assumption has
risen so dramatically. Yeah.
So it's like they were always in this
terrible situation that they're very few
resources in a natural resources, at
least certain, you know, not much water,
you know, kind of a fucked up area. And
now all of a sudden it's just bounty,
bounty,
money and Mercedes.
And everywhere you look is Ferrari's
and Mercedes and Ferrari. Yeah. Do,
we're in Abu Dhabi and who God is.
You never seen guy,
you never seen so many fucking
Bentleys and rolls Royces. Oh,
there's some so big pimpin
going on up in this desert.
Or there was an article recently where
they were talking about how they've
either,
they're admitting that they're making it
rain and I with Dobie that they made it
rain 52 times this year,
throwing money in the air. Oh,
what did that, what, what Jackson had
read, you know what I mean? Like, no,
they just make it rain on the photo.
That photos of these guys in their
traditional garb outside with umbrellas,
you know, standing in front of a
Bentley, by the way, one of the photos,
it's hilarious.
Dudes in front of a Bentley with a
fucking is crazy Arab outfit on holding an
umbrella. I almost bought you
one of those outfits by the way.
Gave me one one off there.
I just didn't have enough to be with
my luggage to bring it back with man.
Fortunately,
yeah,
I pack just to the point where I just
got just enough to get through. Yeah.
You know, I don't want to, I don't have
no room to be bringing shit back with me.
That's my latest thing. I don't check
bags. I just put, I just bring a carry on.
I try to even want to,
it's like a three or four day trip.
I just try to get as little clothes in
there as possible and I'm like, look,
everywhere you can buy
underwear everywhere. You can
buy socks. Right. How do I,
how do I cut this down
to the minimum? Why? Why?
Because when you're waiting in line at
that fucking the the baggage thing and
wondering if your shit's ever going to
come out and let thought it's my favorite
shirt and fuck now I can't get it.
Now I've got to go buy toothpaste.
It's not the baggage fees though,
right?
You got me. You got me. I'm traveling
across the world trying to save 10 bucks
fucking bag.
Anything else before we get out of here?
Pretty much over right.
What time is it?
Five 17 or two hours in two
hours. I'm like 15 minutes. Yeah.
Well thank you everybody for tuning in
and thank you very much for the, um,
the questions that were
answered on Twitter.
Satellites are used to transfer data
overseas and the Internet is back on in
Egypt. So says satellite,
Mister Monkey man.
Eight one eight one eight.
Why is there so many monkey people
on my set of coincidence? Oh,
if you were looking for
higher primates shirts,
a higher-primate.com my clothing line,
we've got a,
we sold out like way quicker
than I thought we're going to.
And that's why unfortunately
a lot of, uh, the, the, uh,
designs have not been in stock,
but we'll restocking them and
I've got a bunch of new dope ones.
They're fucking killer.
I've got to show you some new
ones that we got crazy shit. Um,
this weekend we're going to be at
sales comedy hole in La next weekend.
The Bray Improv,
that's a,
I believe that's Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
I think it's Friday.
Saturday,
Sunday two shows Friday two shows Saturday
one show Sunday as I would have is I
believe so. I'll tell you
right now. Yes you are correct.
And his white before Washington's
birthday, which is Monday, we should,
we should all celebrate together.
Yeah. The last year was a bad ass.
Great President with his wooden teeth
growing weed and bang and slaves.
Slaves, didn't he? Yeah. Crazy world. We
live in folks. Huh? Probably had kids,
but I don't think so. They all
did. Didn't they all shot loads?
Do you think wives get pissed off?
You see this mocha babies wandering
around their yard going in there and
motherfucker different after you're
married to George Washington.
Martha was like, man, my fucking has
really just kept her fucking mouth shut.
He was banging Betsy Ross.
I bet he'd fucked Betsy Ross too.
That's what you got that flag
gig. You know. Come on, man.
Who the fuck is Betsy were up?
Where's Mr. Ross?
You don't even hear shit about Mr. Ross
because George Washington is laying that
fucking deck. So that's
next weekend. Uh, is uh,
Bray improv tickets will sell out.
I hope so.
Get on them all.
That's it.
flashlight.com if you go to Joe rogan.net
and click on the link and put in the
word Rogan,
you get 15% off and a,
we will back be back on Thursday
at three with a genre. Liz Joie,
is that how you say his name is?
You know,
I don't know from the league and
he's from all those hilarious uh,
Internet little white kid or call us
white kid or something like that and uh,
average ordinary guy and that's what I'm,
and I'm so high,
he's got a bunch of weed once he's there.
Anyway. Very cool guy. Very funny guy.
And he'll be on Thursday.
Thank you very much to Chris.
If you go to Chris's website when, when
the fight is over or it's fucking dead.
Dude, I tried to refresh.
We will be resurrected with
your business website again.
[inaudible] dot com in it.com oh,
it's up.
I got on Socrates would kick your ass
and we saw she would paint a nude of your
girlfriend. That's
what's a new blog, blog.
Nine Socrates was probably the most
underrated philosopher I think. And uh,
in that time period, I really, you just
look at, his work is underrated though.
The philosopher really is, is a
warrior. He's, he's, you know,
loud it like everybody
knows he was bad ass.
I mean he carved in or in a car to staff
out of an aura and beat the demon of
the western province. It's
like, people know that,
but I don't think he's got even mean.
You know,
you don't have out of an or what's
an or like a like a rope, like a, Oh,
in order to row boats carved. Just
standing here before and have more of a,
beat the shit out of somebody with it.
Yeah.
He was going to fight the
demon of the western provinces.
But does that mean right? Some
dude, he had a, he had a reputation,
some killer basically, you know,
out there that was a Samurai.
Is that what you're saying? Yeah, that's
the Samurais would fight each other. Uh,
but Socrates you're talking about when
I was talking about Sasha. Oh, okay.
You said Socrates did I baffled
the fuck confused cause I was like,
I just the opposite. Everybody knew
that Musashi was a warrior for sure.
Socrates was a warrior to Socrates.
Yeah,
definitely think that Musashi was one
of the most underrated philosophers.
That's where this whole tattoo came from.
Man,
this is Musashi and it's
based on that quote that stuck
with me my whole life.
Then I read when I was,
I think like 17 that once you
understand the way broadly,
you see it in all things.
Yeah, exactly. And I think one
of the most done, and I'll,
he's a great artist too.
I think people don't know about that.
They just know that he kicked ass.
You know,
what people don't understand is that
that was the Samurai way is that you are,
you were to be balanced and it wasn't,
you know,
you weren't just a thug out there killing
people, but to be a Great Samurai,
to be so well versed that you could kill
men and one on one hand to hand combat,
which he did over 64 times,
killed people in duels,
that he had to be completely
balanced. You know, he had,
he believed that you had to be great at
calligraphy. You had to be great at art,
you gotta be great at poetry.
You know,
you had to have this incredible same
principles that made them great at
swordplay,
could make degrade at anything and the
same principles that made you lazy or
fucked you up or gave you a
shitty character would cost
you your life in battle.
Yeah. Which is so true, man. You know,
and martial artists are starting to
realize that too. Is that all? Any,
any negative energy that you take?
Any, any suggish, Douchey, bullshit.
You have to account for that in your
own assessment of who you are as a human
being, you know, and to, to be truly zen,
you have to really have all
your bases covered to really,
truly in the moment and truly
great at anything. You know,
you've got to be balanced in all
areas, right? For, and folks out there,
too rare. You've got to surround yourself
with positive fucking people. Okay?
And the best way to do this,
the only way to do this,
you've got to become positive yourself.
I know it's difficult. It's not easy.
Yoga socks, it's fucking, there's
a lot of checks fart in that class.
But you gotta go, you gotta go to
Yoga Class, you've got to read things.
Gotta eat healthy. You gotta exercise,
you've gotta get your mind right.
Read books, get up early and run even
though you don't want to. All right,
do chin ups before you eat breakfast.
Do something. Get your shit together,
bitches. And if you get your shit
together, you will attract other people.
Also have their shit together. That is how
I became friends with Chris. All right.
We have attracted each other. Okay. That's
how Brian came here from fucking Ohio,
right, Brian? Yeah, that's
right. Okay, folks, it's fucking
show is over. God dammit.
I'm trying to give you a pep talk
and I'm putting myself to sleep. Um,
this weekend. Like I said, sales
comedy whole next weekend. Bray Improv.
Chris Marcus, thank you
very much for being here, my
friend, rather than a warrior.
poets.us is his website.
redman.com rebend.com we love you
bitches. We always will. All right,
thanks to everybody that came
out in Vegas this weekend.
We had a great fucking
time. I love you. See you.
Bye.
[inaudible].